there's always a thing everyone knows
that crime is really low in japan but
when [ __ ] happens in japan it's from
like zero to a hundred it's like i'm
going to like
burn everyone alive and like post it
like on 2chan
just because i feel like it
i'm gonna do an impression of god
because i'm a guest hello welcome back
to another episode of the trash
taste podcast really that was your
impression of me yeah wow joey
you really you really cut up the trash
taste podcast
oh hello
welcome back to another episode of the
trash taste
podcast the show where we talk about
food [ __ ]
and occasionally anime oh my god i'm
your host for today not gaunt and with
me is gant and the other not gaunt
and i'm a guest i mean i mean i'm a
horror story
with a guest you can tell this is the
first time uh joey's hosting a guest now
i'm i'm not i'm the guest i'm the host
with the guest and the guest is aki
hello hi i'm agnes how are you guys
doing
yeah the long-awaited is this a name
reveal
it is yeah well it's not really a reveal
you can look me up on wikipedia it's
like right there
why'd you have to flex that you have a
wikipedia right off the bat you have one
too
i don't i i i have the you have the
famous birthdays
what does that mean what is that even me
famous birthdays are a plague on the
earth
they keep [ __ ] emailing you asking
for information yeah and also half of
that info is like
kind of not correct yeah yeah i think i
had to email them back like three times
because they kept getting my birthday
wrong
i think there's like a wiki youtube the
one thing you shouldn't get wrong
your favorite birthday isn't it there's
like a wiki youtube and that is more
like
that's also a play yeah yeah yeah that
one's the most
inaccurate wiki of all time there's one
called like celeb dating have you seen
this one
this one has it like wait i think maybe
this one just randomly just takes it and
then it will be like dating and it'll be
like they'll
like summarize if you're dating if
you're married right but they have no
information so everything's just like
speculation unknown unknown oh my god
it would be like you know dog va was
last spotted dating at this time and
it's like 2014.
wow unless you're dating another
youtuber it's kind of creepy to see how
like deep some of these people really
like look back
into your photos and then that like
that's who you are but they don't even
take into account that there's been like
literally so much time
between like this photo and like the
other thing i hate about famous
birthdays is that they use photos from
like
2012 yeah and it's just like oh yeah if
i go look up this person now they're
gonna look exactly like this and then
you realize like an eight-year-old photo
i think like on youtube wiki like they
even have like your top 10 friends like
they've decided like
oh yeah you thought you were friends
and then like sometimes i'll put someone
like i haven't even talked to that
person since like
two thousand i don't know like two
thousand so there's two types of
youtubers who collab often that's people
who only interact through the collab
and yes we interact all the time outside
of the collaboration occasionally
we're youtubers we don't we don't have
friends outside of youtube at all yeah i
mean it depends right on who you meet if
they like to collab a lot and how they
like to
do their youtube friendship like i i
recently went to an event
with like people who had nothing to do
with youtube and
it was just kind of refreshing actually
just to talk to people who are just
doing others people outside of the
internet exactly like wait there are
people that aren't youtubers
yeah yeah our youtubers have nothing to
do with the anime industry because
now that like it's weird because now
that our hobby has turned into our jobs
like we naturally socialize with people
who are just
also to do with our job because that's
our hobby so
it's it was weird talking to people who
were just like working walk
so tldr you went to a bar
with normies yeah guys they're pretty
cool
yeah like i have a whole part of my life
that has like literally nothing to do
with like youtube or anything wow my
[ __ ] earring just fell off anyways
um but anyways so i'm just trying to get
that but there's like a whole part of my
life that has nothing to do with
yeah because i'd say [ __ ] yeah
outside of your earring
yeah i think you're probably one of the
more private youtubers that i've made i
i like how we just
went straight into it and you know yeah
maybe maybe we should maybe you should
explain it
we know we know everything they know
just in case for
what your relationships are and oh my
gosh where should i even begin
just just if you had to explain to
someone at the bar
what your channel was about oh man
you're talking to a norman yeah
i actually like just hang out with
mostly normies
outside of like just youtube and
whenever like
someone who doesn't know who i am like
when they ask oh what do you do i
literally just say i work from home
it's just the easiest thing to say
because the moment that i say that like
i'm a youtuber maybe you guys have like
had this but
i just feel like that just opened so
many doors but that means nothing in
2020 because everyone's working at home
yeah yeah yeah i'm just like oh i do
like marketing
it's just i i try to pick
that's basically how i started
explaining my job to my parents the
first time
i started doing it yeah yeah yeah i i i
have to tell my i have to tell my
grandma that i'm a comedian
it's just like oh i know those yeah but
no like and then i do have like those
moments where i
say that i'm a youtuber and then i just
go into the details what's your youtube
channel about
my youtube channel honestly like people
have just said she's not an anime
channel anymore or she's still in
animation honestly
we can answer that later though yeah
i'm just more of like just an otaku
channel i'm just
someone that lives in japan that just
shares their life and what they like to
do here
but i don't know it's weird because i
still don't really know
what i am because i used to call myself
just anime youtube
but then like i'm too jvlogged to be
anime but then i'm too anime to be
a vlog so i just thought oh otaku
channel that's probably the easiest
thing
he needs labels yeah yeah i'm just
starkey dearest i thought conor's in the
same realm though right it's like yeah
pretty much
people call me not even youtube and i'm
like i don't i mean we both do stuff
around japan like and it's just like
i don't know i feel like as an anime fan
especially when like as an anime fan i
do
all these other things beca in in japan
because when you like anime it just puts
japan in front of you
and then it just puts like all of these
other things so that's why i'm okay with
talking about like
i don't know just like japanese products
or like you know just
when i blew up i talked about vocaloid
because i always just thought
even though it's not an anime it's just
something every anime fan knew
it just somehow made its way it's kind
of just like the weeb culture
yeah yeah yeah essentially i feel like
you don't need to know anything about
anime to watch my content but i feel
like you get a lot more out of it if
you are culturally yeah yeah and that
kind of humor i guess yeah
yeah i feel there's a lot more like
quote-unquote and youtubers who are kind
of going in that direction too like i
i'd say like i'm going in that direction
i think that's where most anime
youtubers going because anime content is
just not performing well because
well not not performing as well yeah as
it was yeah like you can't make like a
30 minutes i think this season's been
really good for anime content but for
the past year it was
pretty rough right like 2020 in 2019 was
really rough
it's funny because i feel like it's
really just the hype that attack on
titan
has brought that people that's just
reminded people oh yeah anime exists
guys anime actually exists
yeah yeah and that's that kind of
trickles down to everything else yeah
but like you can't make like you know a
20 30 minute
analysis video on some seasonal show
that's not the biggest one now and
getting
half of them too much in the first place
i just kind of watched stuff and that's
why i like
because you went to like anime
conventions yeah i went to anime but
like you know
i i mean i was just a pleb like i just
watched [ __ ] but i don't actually like
think that deeply
which is weird because like in the
beginning of my youtube i used to do a
lot more analytical stuff
and one of them i think is like your
favorite series that i dropped yeah a
long time ago
everything you didn't know about right
yeah yeah that one was pretty fun that's
when i did like some detective work
going into an anime of like
what every reference meant my favorite
ones i got so over saturated on youtube
yeah you know what i did eventually 107
things you need to know about naruto
yeah no no it was more like 100 things
you didn't know about naruto but like 97
of them
really obvious i think it was like the
vocaloid videos that popped up
and like the folklore and i think give
me videos that popped up originally
it's literally just one ghibli video
okay and i remember like
there's so i don't know why the [ __ ]
that blew up but yeah no
also vocaloid what's funny is that the
vocaloid video
the first one that went up i originally
was not going to post that
uh because i just thought uh now i'm
just going over like vocaloid songs who
cares but then
and then um the file almost crashed
like uh the the night that i was going
to upload that but then like
looking luckily enough there's like auto
save stuff
so i went through like all these [ __ ] if
i was like please tell me that you saved
it somewhere
and i just uploaded and then the next
morning like actually within that week
then it started to blow up and i
remember um
yeah we were still really early in our
friendship uh and
i think when i blew up i like gotten a
call with you i wanted to like vomit at
like the numbers that were growing
because i didn't know how to handle
because you were getting like
i think it's like 100k a week or
something something ridiculous like that
how did you guys even meet
because i don't think i've ever like
told the story uh we we
have but like oh no it's okay um
so let's see it was like i don't think i
was even at a thousand subscribers but
like 800 i think 700 okay
so i was looking for other youtubers to
talk to so the last time i was on
youtube it was under
another name it's called schoolgirl101
okay amazing
why didn't you stick with that dude
the anime man this
this will all like wrap up to when i
meet joey all right
so i when i was like like 12 or 13 when
youtube was like first starting i had
like
schoolgirl101 and uh i used to
upload a lot of amvs i loved making amvs
and it was like a community and itself
animemusicvideos.org
is anyone here oh god is in that era i
think connor and i were a little too
young for that era oh yeah yeah oh my
god yeah so i
i was that website was religious to me
so i used to upload that stuff and this
is before copyright music and any of
that was a thing so
people like linkin park i absolutely
[ __ ] did it
the amount of times i've watched the one
big upload of amv health three or that
was uploaded to youtube yeah it's just
like uncountable remember we used to
call compilations cracks
yeah dude oh my god i remember that so
yeah no i was uploading amvs
and then i dwelled into i don't know how
but somehow in my deep searching of like
anime related stuff i found
visual novel openings but i couldn't
download visual novels because they were
like really strictly just in japan
but the openings were available on
youtube which i still have those saved
on my current account today
in private but um yeah so then i found
like all these websites and i uploaded
all of like the opening songs on that
and then they were all like hentai so i
got banned so you uploaded hentai onto
schoolgirl 101 yeah
why did you pick the name schoolgirl
one-on-one i i promise it was not
nothing perverted i thought it just
sounded cool and i was watching zoey 101
and i went to school yeah i was trying
to figure out where the 101
yeah yeah because i was watching zoey
101 back then and um
i i was a school girl
but like when i look back i'm like [ __ ]
i think one of my names like xbox best
connor or something
because i'm the best at xbox yeah no the
crew
that's like the same logic honestly i'm
glad that like i got that youtube
account got banned i'm kind of sad all
those amv's like
just like went down like this all those
lincoln paw patrol yeah i know
it was like evanescence and everything i
definitely went down that route
schoolgirl 101 yeah okay
yeah that all got uh that went away and
then i just watched youtube from
behind the scenes then one day i just i
decided i wanted to do youtube i wasn't
even at a thousand subs
and because i was so close in that amv
community all i didn't know where anyone
was anymore so i was like let me get in
another community
joey was the first one that i found that
was closest to my age and i thought that
like he was really funny when he was
playing nicole parra
so the very first message
love it watch it all the time
it wasn't even like the first like the
first video of that nickel power series
but when i was watching it
i just thought that you were really
funny so i was like is youtube dm still
a thing
i've been gone a long
that's time far back we're talking we're
going far back legit like so i
i messaged him on youtube and i said
joe you have it this time oh not even
like 10k i think oh wow
yeah i maybe we were pretty small no i
think i was like
20 30k maybe you needed a fan
so i mentioned the anime man exposed
look okay so i'm from i'm from a part of
youtube where subscribers
actually weren't really that big of a
thing like just anything under like
around that size you know like a
thousand
a bit of a different story if i had like
three million yeah
yeah so i mean like it's whatever but
like when i so i sent him a message and
i said
i called him i called you anime man and
i was like
so [ __ ] weird but hi hi anime man i
saw your nekopara video
thought you were hilarious uh do you
like dojins if you want let's read one
together
no you found you found this [ __ ]
pokemon version of god of war yeah and
i just like we should read it on camera
together and i was like all right so i
got a call with her no no no hold on but
there's something in the toilet
but like because it was youtube dms i
was not expecting a reply because i was
like
i think it was like 2014-15
times have changed but my mind was so
all the way back but
literally in an hour you replied back to
me and you told me that like
later on that you had not really looked
at your youtube dm's until that night
and i was at the very top and had you
not seen it that yeah
this one it was like purely coincidental
yeah and then afterwards who the [ __ ]
went through the youtube
exactly i think youtube got rid of it
now right
yeah i think it still technically exists
somewhere yeah
hello anime man i mean that's the
beginnings they're right
but there is there's a video on his
channel of where i still called him
anime man it's when we were playing uh
what orange juice one hundred some some
shitty yeah orange juice 100
or so i'm doing it for them like it was
what was it called oh i don't want them
to look at the video
that's what i'm trying to mean so i'm
trying to be inconspicuous there's some
shitty anime yeah
yeah i don't know what i'm talking about
don't put it on the screen i swear to
god
well yeah so we were just really good
friends for like a couple years
and then he got trapped in canada and
now you gotta explain why i got trapped
in canada you can't just say that oh
yeah
because then he i lost my possibility
yeah
yeah he lost his passport he was really
stressed but i had no idea that you were
in canada
but this is like we had been friends for
a long time and we had been calling so
frequently i was like i'm gonna just
tell him i like him i don't even care
i'm just getting a call and that was
then
like you were still at your hotel
stressed out your mind i was like i
really like you
now it's not the time
did you was there a process where you
thought about this is the right time to
tell him or you were just like
he's mine right now i didn't know that
he was in canada i didn't know that he
was trapped there
i didn't know that you were like going
through other [ __ ] i was like i'ma just
tell him or whatever
i i hadn't eaten in like two days
because i was so stressed out
and the first thing i get is like i like
you from anki dearest and i was like
there's a denny's down the road like i'm
[ __ ] starving
no but then you know what's funny you
were so disoriented and also like
um so i don't know if anyone knows this
but i'm joey's first girlfriend like a
real girlfriend like proper girl
proper girlfriend he had you had seen
some other people in the past
past but but it was like high school
relationships like i didn't count both
yeah yeah so
um what was funny is i think he was so
dense like i literally
said the words i like you a lot and then
he said wait
are you saying what i think you're
saying and then i said and then i said i
think i said it
i am i am dead ass of that dense like
harem protagonist
i don't know what are you saying what
are you trying to say what are you
trying to say right
i think i said it yeah so um
yeah but from there like uh actually
like i think we talked for like 10 or 15
hours like that day
and yeah because i had nothing else to
do because i was in my [ __ ] toronto
villa that was a special moment i miss
being like 19 and just being able to
spend all day on a skype call yeah right
yeah that that we speak people do that
all the time like
and it's like and it was like with that
group of friends where it's like it
didn't matter if nobody talked
yeah yeah like you were just on it
what's the longest skype call you guys
have ever been
in together or just just in general i
think it was the one with her where i
was i was in a skype call for like
12 hours yeah 12 hours and then after
that i think
uh when time came like you went you
finally got back to australia and then
we gave it time to think and we're like
and we were both blowing
up around like the same time and then
our channels were yeah
i can't hear the word flying out without
thinking about that meme but that guy's
like when i blow up
i don't know nobody yeah sorry
because no it's cool and then uh
whenever when our careers were like
finally taking off
we just kind of got in a talk and said
this isn't going to work
and we're too busy and i don't know i
feel like well it's also because i was
in my last year of uni at the time and i
was
stressed out of my [ __ ] mind because
i'm like if i don't knuckle down on this
[ __ ] i'm not going to graduate
yeah i've been playing corpse party 18
hours yeah yeah i can't i can't
i can't be doing free translations for a
corpse party visual novel like i gotta
[ __ ] knuckle down so like so that was
like so at that point like
i not only like ghosted you i i ghosted
everyone
watching yeah yeah i like it like three
months last year the last year of uni do
be like that yeah yeah yeah so i'm
and then in the meanwhile i was just
kind of doing my own thing fast forward
though ax comes around
and then we both message each other and
i think that was also like my samurai
buyer video had just come out that day
and that's when you dm
good old samurai and then uh
i was uh i guess we just got like this
private talk but i was just like okay
yeah we're going to ax
um i'll see you there and so we met and
yeah i guess it was ax 2016.
i think so yeah yeah that was that was
like i think
watching you guys at ax because before
we even like did we speak at that point
i think so
we spoke but we had a mitt i think so
that was when i was like
i don't care i'm going to ax next year i
felt so left out seeing how much fun it
was
i was like was that the ax i first met
you or was that the eggs before that
was the before i think it was the ax
what was it before
i don't remember i remember it's it's it
might have been the it might have been
the one
no it might have been that ax it was
that it was that ax yeah
i think my first one was 2017 ax yeah
yeah so my one was
20 20 15 i think 2016 yeah because
you've been a few times before me right
yeah that's right yeah 2016 was the
first year i met you and jeff
yeah yeah that's right but i think i'd
gone to one before that i don't know if
anyone else would win
that's gone no i've gone to ax like
every year since i was like
13. i'm so jealous so you've seen so
you've seen
the scene evolve over time it's honestly
just been so [ __ ] great like it's uh
i was maybe almost
14 or 15. oh my god yeah i was 14 or 15
my first and acts 2013
yeah not even i think it's like 2010.
and that was back then where like the
line was big but it went by
fast like day zero wasn't a problem yeah
now seeing it nowadays like i loathe
daisy
like i don't mind yeah yeah yeah line
con basically
so yeah i know it's been crazy to see um
like just kind of the progression of
things and i used to watch
videos of ax back in 2007
and if you look at any vlogs of ax of
2007
they will say oh my god it's like so
packed here literally it's just like the
it's like 3 000 people yeah but that was
a lot back then you know i mean
it's it's the pd flow videos there yeah
because i watched exactly the same thing
because i remember back in who is this
oh sorry no go for it okay so it's
basically a guy who
seemed to be very influenced by kasem g
like some
you know the old cassandra good old
casual old youtubers but what he would
basically do
is just he would go around ax every year
and just vlog it and do interviews and
slightly yeah in the ksmg kind of style
and me trying to point them out to be
kind of like yeah yeah yeah exactly and
me
as a weeb growing up in like the mid
2000s
never been to a convention in my life
and especially the uk uk
exactly especially in the uk scene
seeing these vlogs this was like mecca
to me you know
i i remember watching these vlogs and i
remember thinking i'm gonna be there one
day
i'm gonna be there one day it was legit
like the greatest thing i had ever seen
in my
life like okay by the way if you guys
ever want to look at him pdf i don't
know if you're still around watching
this
but it's like p e p e e p d it'll be
on screen p literally pd yeah looking at
the ax vlogs i was like this is blowing
my [ __ ] i think one thing i was
always jealous
of americans is that like it just seems
like they just accept any side of like
weird culture yeah yeah yeah yeah uk and
probably australia as well right it felt
that like if you were into
stuff that wasn't like super normal it
felt like that was pulling material
yeah yeah yeah exactly alex brought
money and money yeah
like watching like being from the uk or
australia watching american conventions
or like seeing just the way that they
treat nerd culture in general and yes
i was always so jealous one of the
reasons why i always wanted to move to
the us
i mean obviously now it's very different
yes
kids have an easy time i didn't give a
[ __ ] back then i was like i'll go
anywhere right
because back then to me america was like
this whole like mystical place and then
obviously now mystical place
it was like it was like a place where
everyone could just do what they wanted
yeah and like
everyone could like like whatever they
wanted yeah there's always a huge
always like a huge place to go if you
liked a specific thing that was always a
big convention
i think it's also because like
especially compared to like the uk
especially like america was just so much
[ __ ] bigger right so there's just it
just felt like there was more stuff
there was like huge nerds and like
otaku's in the uk but
because you were again you were just
like looking down we couldn't find each
other that was the biggest thing because
with in america it seems like
there was always a place for somewhere
wherever you wanted to belong
yeah and i remember looking at ax or or
like all these con videos and thinking
man god i wish that was yeah
i look like i belong there oh my god i
remember when i went to my very very
first convention
and i just felt like this was right like
i knew that this was where my heart was
supposed i fought that too when i took
eventually yeah
yeah because then it's just like
remember the fact that like because we
could not find each other and even in
the u.s it was still like this was more
online than anything but when you found
someone's like oh
you like naruto too like oh and then you
just instantly connected well in
australia there wasn't even an online
scene
like i feel like like almost like in
america like i don't know if this is
true but like parents kind of like
are more accepting of like weird hobbies
yeah
in the uk man my parents would give me
[ __ ] yeah my parents were like that
like come down for dinner be like oh
it's the anime fan
yeah my parents used to like be really
kind of like weirded out about the fact
i liked the anime but now
my parents are very rare for their
generation they love youtubers and
streamers they tell me [ __ ] that even
like i haven't caught up to yet
like yeah yeah yeah like they they know
literally everyone and then uh so
what's funny is like i'm logged into my
youtube account also on
uh the one at home back in vegas the
reason for that is because
because of time zones my mom checks to
see if i got like a content
like copyright claim and she goes to my
account and then
she's literally your manager like she
she claims that for me and then i wake
up the next morning i was like mom did
you claim the story she's like yeah i
was just looking at it well my mom's
like who's your swiss friend ppd
my mom will occasionally go and there's
been a big youtuber in the news
i heard this logan fellow i couldn't
believe it
do you know him
my parents are have definitely done
their hardest to try and like keep up
with the times
yeah my parents do try but they're just
two out of it
yeah yeah my parents are the same my
parents have really changed since trash
taste started because that's just given
them so much content to watch
and now it's gotten to the point where
every single clip and every single
now we have like official and then
unofficial clip streams as well yeah and
that's all been recommended to her
and she watches she watches like way
more content than i do now
just purely off like us i guess yeah my
parents are kind of just like
you know we don't like support what you
do you just kind of do it
yeah so we don't support what you do but
you do your own human challenge no
no no my dad you do not support joey
and his job no my dad's straight like in
the q a that i did with my dad my dad
was straight up like
i don't really like support what you do
i just kind of let you do it i'm like
thanks dad the only thing about having
parents that are so in tune with what i
do is like
that would annoy me i would it wouldn't
annoy me giving me feedback about my
thumbnails
my dad doesn't give a [ __ ] about what i
do and yet he's still like yeah son i
didn't really like that video you made
it like same as my friends
yeah no and then dude my parents like
like they used to back when it was like
used more they looked at like social
blades and stuff like they were
they're very into like that's like a
little too i don't look at my own social
media i don't want my parents to yeah
my my dad was he went through a point
when he was just literally
clicking and refreshing it and i was
just like dad
this is not healthy why are you doing
this please that's kind of cute though i
don't know why
it's like oh i want to see you girl
yeah i occasionally get my mom she'll be
like oh the last video i didn't do as
well as the other videos yeah
my dad would sometimes phone me and be
like son last week you only grew like
1 000 subscribers oh my god normally you
grow like 2 000
what's going on what is your channel is
your channel dying your channel channel
dying what's going on
yeah my my dad right now he's like
having his own version of like you
winning son it's more like oh yeah
your video doing well like it's just
every upload he just said has the sex
this episode is sponsored by liquid iv
guys you know i love drinking water
do it plenty on the podcast plenty of
pee breaks and one goal i have for
myself for the new year is just to stay
hydrated and i do that with my favorite
hydration product liquid iv
with one stick of liquid iv in 16 ounces
of water you get
two to three times the amount of
hydration as plain water
that's water optimized and they have
incredible hydration flavors like
watermelon lemon lime passion fruit and
they've recently launched strawberry
i like strawberry i do too personally i
really like liquid iv because i just
like flavored water in general so if i
can get extra hydration off of
something i already enjoy in concept
then honestly
you know when you wake up from a
hangover and sometimes you drink so much
water that the taste of water just
starts to get sickening
yeah yeah this actually tastes really
good and this would be perfect for a
hangover day
honestly i do like the watermelon flavor
so i'll give them that yeah i like the
watermelon flavor too one serving of
liquid iv products the same hydration
drinking two to three bottles of water
alone and it contains five essential
vitamins more vitamin c than an average
orange
and as much potassium as a banana and
it's healthier than sugary sports drinks
no artificial flavors or preservatives
and less sugar than an apple
made with clean ingredients non-gmo
vegan and free gluten dairy-free and soy
so you can grab your strawberry liquid
iv
or their other great flavors in bulk
nationwide at any costco
and you can get 25 off when you go to
liquidive.com and use
code trash taste at checkout that's 25
off anything when you order and use
promo code trash
taste at liquidive.com get better
hydration today
at liquid iv.com promo code trash taste
back to the episode uh
what are we talking about you said you
didn't really want to be a youtuber
when did
when i started youtube i i mean i didn't
intend to be a youtuber or anything like
that i don't think anyone is
uh you just kind of do it i don't think
anyone just wait like because i just
made this video because i thought i
could make this funny video and i wanted
to show my friends so i was like i'm
going to make this for me
and my friends yeah yeah and i just put
it up put in a nice little package
and then i thought one and done that's
it i'm i feel that's like the kind of
secret formula to being a successful
youtuber right it's like people who
start a youtube channel with the intent
of like
yeah i'm gonna be the [ __ ] next
pewdiepie it's like it never works
i'm curious like what did what made you
wanna so
the first video what was your first
video as well
that wasn't like oh i remember um
i think it's still on there it's i was
playing this visual novel of uh
dramatical murder
oh okay yeah yeah and it's literally
like a five minute
clip because it was like during a like
the final scene of like me
trying to get with like one heavy
breathing actually it was it wasn't
it was it was it's still on my channel
um and
it's me and my mic it's me and my
microphone i was like
okay guys so i just got uh clear here
let's uh let's see oh my god
it's like me just doing that the whole
time was it like the whisper scream like
yeah yeah because it was because it was
like 12. i did i think my first
that made my first video which was like
christmas your parents were in the house
yeah they were
so i was like yeah so i was super like
you know minecraft youtuber
like oh my god i can't believe this is
happening right now but
yeah so that was my first one and then i
was kind of i think i knew
no i knew i wanted to do youtube once i
got my first paycheck um
no it's literally with anything when you
figure out that oh my god i can get paid
for something
yeah yeah yeah so um i don't know
like so there was a video uh i'm not
gonna say
what blow up but what blew up but it
blew up and then i got my first paycheck
and it was three hundred dollars and i
remember
i felt like the big doe no no no i mean
i mean you say that but at that time
that was a lot of
what's weird is like this is going to
sound like really cheesy but i felt
like i was at a crossroads here that
that 300
was perfect for the rest of my meals for
college for the rest of the month
or that was the perfect amount to get
lights and a better camera um
so i went that way and my mom was very
concerned about the choice that i made
but i was like you know what like this
is just money from youtube so if this
doesn't work it's not like it was my own
like my own money from work i was i used
to work in a movie theater
um and then yeah once that happened i
remembered how much i loved making
videos from like the schoolgirl 101
and i was like [ __ ] and then i just felt
like this fire going on and i was like i
i want to do youtube i knew from that
point i wanted this to work i was going
to give myself a year
to uh to try and make this work so what
i did
and it i guess it's questionable to some
but i told
all my friends around me that you're not
going to see me for a year like because
i want to do this because i had a
part-time job as a full-time student
getting my psychology degree
and i only had time for one other thing
and that was youtube so i did that
and then also i was in a relationship
and that person didn't
want me to do it at all and i had cut it
like when we had we had
i tried talking it out and anyone who
would stop you from doing something
you're passionate
yeah yeah probably isn't the one for you
yeah no and i knew right then and there
that like
youtube was what i wanted from that
moment on and when he said he didn't
want me to do it
i had no problems cutting
you're like it was understandable
no i just like and i you know also i
mean it was
a lot of pressure to try and balance a
relationship out and
you know give it a year i remember i
would
i would go to school go straight to work
and then because i had to like come back
at like midnight after the last showing
um then i would work until like
sometimes up until 7am
i think you know back when you first
start you have like no problem with it
yeah
yeah yeah yeah because it's at the time
it's not like it's something new right
it's only later on when you you've been
doing it for a while and you realize
holy [ __ ] this is unhealthy as [ __ ]
at the beginning you think whoa i'm
getting paid to do something i like
well this this is this i'm just going to
keep going now this is just a life hack
i can do this forever well in psychology
we do say that like um
a job is when you say uh oh i only got
paid that much for doing all that a
career is when you say wow i got paid
that much for just doing that
you know so i mean it's pretty true
big brain yeah so uh there was that yeah
and so since then
like youtube's just had its ups and
downs but i've loved it ever since i
don't
you've been doing it for what how many
years now five six maybe
like six when did you start like 2014
right i uploaded my first video 2014
but then that's what and then i blew up
in 2015. i think
i feel like since i met you your like uh
perspective on youtube has changed it
has a lot
i feel like you were the one who's like
the most grindy out of anyone i knew
yeah and then you like flipped the
opposite where like i hit never hear you
talk about it
yeah when you do it's always like one
big thing that you're working i think
it's because like especially with
personality
like you just i don't know so at some
point you just
want to get grounded again and you just
realize youtube isn't everything it's
still something i love to do
and now it is just my job and now i i
don't really
that that fire of me wanting to like you
know i want to grow as like a youtuber
i'm already there
so i'm just like now i just kind of want
to go back to my roots and that's why i
just kind of like
just talk with like my other personal
friendos um does that just happen like
over time
over time yeah yeah youtube just does
some weird stuff to you i think fame
does that a lot as well and
just like the pressure of being a
personality there's like now this whole
part of my life
that has nothing to do with what i do um
and i think you already know like some
stuff that i do in private like just for
fun
was that a point where you realized that
or was it was it something like with
that gradual that like
i think it was a i think it was a
gradual thing um because
i feel like if you're some people you
know love being in the spotlight and
love having the attention on them and
then others i i meet
and they're just like they get crushed
by it yeah yeah because i feel like
some some youtubers who i've met who
their youtube is so intertwined with
not not not only their job but their
self-worth as well yeah
and it's like if i'm not successful on
youtube then i'm not successful as a
person
i'd say though it was like the first
time i started to feel like i was
looking at it like a job was like really
scary
because i was like am i losing my touch
i'm like am i going to be a bad youtuber
now
yeah because i'm not i'm not like
thinking about it 24 7. yeah
the first few months i was really
struggling to like kind of just
understand that like it's okay to like
not
think about this all the time right yeah
um yeah and then now i feel like i have
a pretty healthy balance with it where i
don't honestly don't really think about
it that much
i kind of plan what i need to do i think
it also helps as well that like
especially you and i have really like
gone down in terms of like how sporadic
we upload because like we used to upload
way more frequently yeah you should try
and do two a week and that's what i used
to be daily dude yeah
daily is like i don't know how you do
that but yeah i went from daily to i
went from daily to weekly
you know so [ __ ] psychos right here
you used to upload as well right no i
didn't i used to upload just three times
a week that's it
just three times it really wasn't that
bad i mean joey
at the time like yeah you did upload
daily i was like three times a week
but that's what youtube wanted back then
yeah yeah yeah three times a week i
don't think would work now
it would be unoptimized yeah i think i'm
at a point now like
maxine i think i'm at a point now where
like i just upload like
like once a week i think the audience
has changed i think audiences would just
rather get something
well i think i think two weeks is kind
of long but one week just a good video
once a week and it seems to do the job
yeah no pretty much because it's so
saturated now so yeah and there's so
much trust me a lot of time
to just live my life rather that because
youtube's kind of weird i feel like
people kind of
uh go on either side of the spectrum
it's either like it's like the business
versus like the artist
if you are too far into the artist then
you kind of lose focus on like how your
business is doing and some people don't
care about that which is fine
but then you get people who like care
about the numbers way too much and then
it kind of integrates into their life
and their self-worth and
even just the people that they hang out
with like unless they're a big youtuber
i won't hang out with them
kind of thing definitely
it's sad because i've seen both sides
and i think it's just
like that side like i've seen that so
frequently which is why like i'm like
okay i don't
i don't want to fall into that so i
decided to back up and just
make my own private life really
infuriates me when i've had people who i
thought were good friends and then maybe
i like introduce them to one of my
friends and they're not like a youtuber
and they'll be like i don't care who
they are
yeah i think that's the biggest tell for
me where especially because you know
whenever we travel
or something like that we always try to
bring our friends with us right even if
they're not youtubers or
doing something else if they're peasants
if we bring them along it's fun
normies there's commoners imagine
working in an office job
you know like we always hear it as kind
of a joke but it's true sometimes you
i i hate saying it like this but
remember the little people but more like
remember your roots
go back to that and like i just i just
think because normally youtubers tend to
hang out with other youtubers because
like the lifestyle is similar yeah i
mean like you're just there and that's
fine like you can make youtuber friends
i just don't like it when people like
yeah and it's obvious like you it's so
obvious
a lot of the times where it's like oh hi
like you know when they start like
sucking another big youtuber's dick so
hard like to the point it's just like
then the point like what is the point of
that friendship if all you ever want is
just like your friendship only exists on
youtube but if it doesn't exist
like outside of youtube then it's like
because for me like to tell
the telltale sign of that might be
happening with someone that i know is
when
the only times they will ever dm me is
for youtube
and that's where i'm just like oh okay
like you don't give a [ __ ] about me
at all i've had a few messages where
it's like it's really obvious that
the only time they message is when they
need something which is also why i very
rarely do collabs on my channel
the people i've done collabs on my
channel is people like i genuinely had
like a connection with
because i'm very much a person that will
show their emotions on camera um because
i'm not gonna fake anything
so like for example just recently i just
collaborated with charlotte and emma but
those are two people that i've been
friends with for years and just recently
have i felt comfortable enough to
actually do a video with them yeah
that's if anyone wanted to know why i
don't collaborate with that many
youtubers that's why and it's also the
introvert in me
any introvert will understand that like
we keep the people like we're very picky
with people but the people that we do
pick we keep very tightly
yeah yeah you're very much like the
opposite to me on that i'm like
yeah same i'm like hell yeah come on
let's go let's go hang out yeah but like
and that's fine like i just you know
it's so easy for me it's easier because
then i just know like what people i
already know want to hang out
like at night but when there's too many
people i feel like man i got to balance
everyone out and then i don't
like it's too many people it's hard to
maintain yeah a little bit
just for me i just hope that like you
know the people i make friends with that
like you know they're
they don't expect me to like the actual
friends i actually don't expect anything
out of it
yeah like they understand if we're like
we're both busy you know
yeah yeah i don't know like uh yeah it's
it's not about like you know i'm friends
with this person to get
something out yeah exactly because for
me i
don't do collabs on my channel at all
that's just because my content i felt
doesn't really lend well to collabs
especially since like it's very scripted
content so
i just want to hang out with people i
don't care i'd like never care about the
collabs that's
never in my mind i just like meeting new
people well that's the thing right it's
like
you know i've probably only collapsed
with like half the youtubers i actually
have become friends with
yeah that's just purely because some
youtubers i know where it's like
it doesn't matter how much i've been
this concept of like anime content
there's just no way i can integrate
their personality what they're about
into the content yeah yeah and you know
nothing against the youtubers i know
it's just
it's just how the content not even
against collabs because you know
watching you guys collab i'm just like
man that seems kind of fun it is fun
it's really fun and there's a part of me
where it's like i really want to be able
to like
make content that i can literally get
any type of youtuber onto
but because i [ __ ] i [ __ ] myself over
with what i've called myself
yeah right so like i can't really you
know just do like a [ __ ] outfit of
the day [ __ ] and bringing on like you
know just a female youtuber right so
that's one of the biggest things
i worry about as well is just the
chemistry because sometimes i see people
collab
and like you know that's you you can
tell on camera that that's the first
time
ever had like had a like irl
conversation
yeah exactly i actually recently did a
video where i got my fortune told in
japan
and i even yeah and uh there's like two
things that are happening so i show like
the actual raw footage of me talking to
the fortune teller i had never
met her before in my life so my
introvertedness actually came out in
that where i only said like
one word answers but to be fair i was
also listening because she had a lot to
say
it was a lot for me to process but then
there's the part of me that's like in my
room where i was
actually very outspoken and i think i
even said in that video i'm like yeah
you're looking at two different aggies
here
that aki right there is actually the
introverted one and i'm just listening
the ones that's the real one
no but and then the one that you're
seeing right now is just my thoughts and
i'm comfortable to
get them out right now because i i think
when we hang out it's like very
different to when we hang out and
there's someone else there you don't
really know
pretty much and that's then that's with
every like anyone that like
you know when there's someone that's new
i mean again like i've learned this in
psychology but you tend to look at the
person that you're most comfortable with
even if you're talking
to someone else it's like yeah uh you
guys went to that park right yeah um
okay yeah
like i language just says so much about
it and i'm definitely sorry i'm making
eye contact right away
i actually had to learn how to make eye
contact because as a skill i think you
know
as a kid was like a socially awkward
queer kid i'd be talking
kid i'd be talking to someone and be
like yeah how's your day going yeah it's
it's
i have no idea where i learned social
skills how do you learn that [ __ ] i
swear i was terrible
i don't know i think you're just like
especially when you become an adult
you you're forced to because like if
you're that one like adult where
you just can't maintain i can't talk to
anyone as a kid like i was terrible yeah
i never learned
like i've never i've never talked to
someone and being like i have to keep
looking to the right i have
really actually there's there's been one
anime that's been airing the season
um and it's like we just need to remind
you guys that this is an anime podcast
because it's like relevant to me and
that's why i really uh i'm watching it
and it's like
i think it's like jakku or something
like that is a bottom tier character
oh yeah yeah it's about this like pro
gamer who has like zero social skills
and he meets
like this hot anime girl it's like it's
like a harem rom-com but
the premise is that she teaches him
social skills
like they're a game so like he he like
he she he she gamifies she's she gave a
question
look at that yeah no no exactly she's
just like okay so
this this brought uh this person brought
up x topic and that like really
defined the flow of this conversation
and it really like broke down
like social skills and social circles
and like gamified them and that was like
really interesting to me because
that's basically what i had to do in
university because i was just like
this is not natural to me i've got to
[ __ ] engineer this [ __ ]
and then and then it became second
nature along the way but like i needed
those training wheels
when i was learning it because i was
like that socially awkward
but that's like a cool way to learn it
right like because it's like it's a
concept that you can kind of
understand yeah it's like i think
there's a healthy way and an unhealthy
way to go about it because some people
just like take this and like gamify it
too much that they just kind of become a
robot and i feel like it's it's healthy
it's like look at this person and then
look at this person and then look at
this person
it's just it's just helpful it's just
health was like it's kind of like
training wheels eye contact is hard like
too little and then you're like
talk to me too much it's like i've met
those people where it's like
hard eye contact that just they don't
even blink i'm just like that's
like i'm talking to an android just
occasionally look right look away look
back
yeah yeah what's happening you know
exactly exactly
who teaches this [ __ ] how do i learn
this [ __ ] i don't know no one does no
one does teach you you know it's one
thing that drives me insane
some people do and some people don't do
if okay let's say we're all here right
and then you know let's say aki brings a
friend
okay to the group it drives me insane
when the person who brought the friend
in doesn't introduce them to everyone
yeah i'm like i'm waiting who is this
person you're gonna they're awkward for
them
do you know one of the biggest things
that i found is important even though i
never thought about it as like a kid
the handshake yeah
now that we've met like now that we've
gone through like met so many people you
can judge so much about a person by just
their handshake
yeah exactly yeah exactly it's an entire
process and it's like an entire science
behind it
sometimes someone whips out like the
weakest handshake and you're just you're
not looking forward to this hand
it is like it is like the slimiest
coldest like wet hair
or like or like you know when they just
do this and they're just waiting for you
yeah sometimes
sometimes you just feel like you're
grabbing like a dead piece of me and
you're just like
hello how how are you i love it i love
it when the
strength comes out they turn their body
slightly yeah
the strongest ones that i've learned is
like you know the the shoulder out front
a little bit but also
going in while maintaining eye contact
like that don't even look at the hands
that's what my dad did to you the first
time he met you yeah
that was more of like uh saying a
message he did it like this like just
shake
if i was like my dad and you were joey
it's like
he like whipped the hand out i was like
oh [ __ ] i had to catch this
yeah and then after that i remember like
uh that my dad he boxes and we have also
like a sandbag in our garage
and then like joey's just like you want
to see the uh my new sandbag and he
[ __ ] punches the [ __ ] out of him he's
like oh it's pretty good huh
yeah and i was like maintain eye contact
yeah but yeah my life's kind of weird
i'm sorry
yeah i remember i'll never can i tell
the story of when i had dinner with your
family without you
is that london oh my lord
i have dinner with aki and a whole
family without a key there
family was staying in a hotel in london
but i think it was quite ex i mean
hotels in london are very expensive
yeah but i wanted to give it as a gift
for them yeah so they were staying in a
nice in bank
quite a nice area of london uh quite
posh yeah meanwhile these two are just
staying at my house
not even in the same city yeah yeah
quite far away
it's like the airport was gatwick so
it's like 30 minutes up 30 years yeah so
i i had connor kind of helping my family
i felt so bad because uh it was like in
the middle of uh
july or august it was during the heat
wave yeah
and i took them on the underground on
the central line which is basically like
the yamanote
yeah i took them on the worst busiest
train with all
their luggage it was so hot and i was
like i'm so sorry
i could tell aki's dad was like having a
mental breakdown
because it was so hot yeah so much
luggage and there's no ac in the uh
to their hotel and i think it's thanks
they were like let's let's let's invite
connor out for dinner so i just had a
dinner
with meanwhile chilling in brighton
joey was like on my hammock or something
yeah
yeah i remember conor texting me he's
like i'm so sorry my mom's watching this
too
like your food is lovely that you
prepare for
but yeah no i remember just texting me
being like dude i feel so [ __ ]
but your mom's always so nice to me so
shows when we feel really welcomed
yeah yeah yeah still mom's nice to
everybody i feel like yeah she is
it's very hard to piss your mom off your
parents are always super open and super
nice
yeah i like the way they i
like books
your parents are just like if you're a
friend of ackie you're part of the
family yeah
pretty much yeah and even more kudos if
you're a youtuber or streamer because
like at the moment they find that out
they'll keep like do you did you guys
give me your answers right now like did
you guys watch harry potter
did you guys watch harry potter you know
ron's dad like being really obsessed
with um
like muggles yeah that's my parents like
with youtubers and streamers
like that's like so this is a different
breed of [ __ ] i remember
like uh that my mom like she got uh she
texted me being like
oh my god beldelfina's back and i was
like what
she was like how do you think her only
fans is going i was like i don't know
i don't care dude like yeah so my
parents are very like on point
i feel that whole like welcoming side of
your parents especially though like i
feel
ties in with like kind of how the you
know the filipino like mentality yeah so
my family
funny enough we actually are all
introverts but when you meet them you
wouldn't think so it's mainly because if
you're a friend
of mine then they'll more than be happy
that to open people
i feel like we're giving me food i was
like that's that's
the phil that's the selfie station she
was an ax and her mum was checking up on
me more than my mum was
like what's going on i don't know what
it is about southeast asian parents just
families where
they try to solve every [ __ ] life
problem yeah by offering food
aki's mom has bought me more underwear
and socks than my own kids
that says a lot yeah my mom she always
like delivers uh just some stuff from
overseas and she always gets like six
bags of like cheetos
like every time when i was a kid that
i'd visit my family
i'd even be like oh you don't seem like
you're eating well here have more food
oh are you feeling well
here have more food oh you're not
feeling well it's cause you haven't
eaten how about you yeah yeah yeah
and if you're fat then they'll just be
like oh you're getting so fat eat
yeah which is weird you know like i
don't know if it's like in any other
family i just noticed with a lot of
asian families
being called fat is a good thing because
it means that you're being
you're you're being fed that's right i
feel that's a specifically southeast
asian thing yeah yeah yeah it's like oh
you're so
fat now oh my god do you have a
boyfriend like it's
yeah so it's always because that's not
how it works in japan like even even if
you lose weight
or like gain muscle you're like damn you
got fat i was like
i just gained muscle but all right
thanks thanks for destroying my
self-esteem
there's definitely one thing about asian
culture that's like very different from
the west where
people aren't afraid to comment on other
people's weight yeah right yeah where
it's a very like
you know it's a very sensitive topic in
like if you comment on someone else's
weight
in england or the u.s especially but
here in here in asia it's a free-for-all
yeah you know we're just we're just
saying what we're seeing right here
yeah you just you just meet like the
amount of family reunions or family
gatherings i've got i've gotten to uh
i've been too sorry
and people just the first thing they say
is like damn you're getting a bit fat
aren't you
and i'm like ma i'm [ __ ] satisfied
what are you talking about
i remember the finished guy i remember i
went though when we were
staying at garn's place and then like i
don't eat spicy food which i know is
like really blaspheming
uh in southeast asia it is yeah i know
sorry and but i remember like
your mom was gonna make us food and then
she asked like is there anything that
aki can eat and you said oh she can't
eat spicy food and then she's like
i'm making curry what do i do
she tried to she tried to work her on it
and it was like those amazing [ __ ]
spiciness
like dance mom dead ass came up to me
and was like i have never made a thai
car without each other
i don't even know if it's gonna taste
good at all like i've never done this
before yeah they're still really good i
had never had like those like what is it
like those noodles
it's like a southeast asian it's like a
rice noodle yeah it's like a rice
noodles
i can't remember the name right now it's
[ __ ] good thai people are fuming
right now yeah
huh it's not very much healing oh yeah
what's even the english name of that
like
i don't know rice noodles right it's
like yeah it's just like these piles of
like noodles and then you just take them
and dip them in the curry
i think i don't know it's on the screen
mood on you can figure it out i don't
know i don't know what it is but
every every southeast asian is just like
[ __ ] my own language i don't know at
what age i realized there was more than
one type of noodle
wow yeah how did you like as a white man
as a token white man
like i feel like your view of noodles
was like my view of bread
because like for me everybody yeah every
bread was just the same
i'm sure i'm saying this and everyone in
europe just like dies a little
what bread is so varied yeah there's
definitely way more types of bread than
there are noodles though
no no
we're gonna we're gonna have to actually
can you look up to see if there is there
are
more types of bread than there are types
of noodles
i think there are more types of noodles
no there is not yeah
we'll figure that out no pasta no
pasta's not pasta's lost
yes i'll have a i'll have a noodle
bolognese
well at least you don't try to eat it
with chocolate we're going to start
world war three or that one coming up
yeah
we should stop talking about food we
should stop talking about food so uh you
mentioned
your real name at the beginning of this
episode yeah my name is agnes
is there anything would you say it like
that yeah my name is you're saying it
like an android
my name is agnes for the record not even
my family calls me that
it so that's why i also didn't come out
with it because it was
guess yeah but like what is there like
anything else
i mean i guess we're just going to
dedicate this trash taste to like
new things that aki's never said 107
things you didn't didn't know about
hockey dearest
oh god uh okay i don't even know where
to start i mean like
i was mentioning earlier i could
probably talk about the fact that i was
in military school for like or
military class for like four years and
what is that
yeah what what so it's called nj rotc
navy junior reserve officer training
corps
and it's damn that was drilled into you
man yeah how many times did you have to
repeat that
what's the purpose of this it's when you
want to go into the military and so when
you want to go into the military
yes to fight for their country
um but yeah i noticed that's a very
american thing it's yeah because like
i i feel like it's very patriotic yeah
it's very patriotic because in england
nobody talks about
wanting to go to the military yeah i
feel like i almost didn't send
themselves in there
i you rarely hear about kids who are
like 15 16 who want to go in the army
yeah that's their parents in it right
right yeah
so it i remember when i came out on
twitter i was just like oh you know
cause uh my mom had showed me like a
like this old photo album and there was
one of me in high school in my dress
blue so
sorry uh that's the term for the uniform
and um i was like oh [ __ ] you know what
i never actually came out about that and
that was like a huge part of my life
what age do you start that uh when the
moment you hit high school you can do it
so what what'd you have to decide to do
that or your parents decided i did
because you from age like 14 yeah you
like decided i want to join them
so i did not join so no no no no okay so
my reasoning for joining wasn't exactly
for like the most patriotic reason it
was because uh
had a crush back in high school he he he
was part of it and then he was like oh
yeah
like it's pretty cool in here and then i
joined and it didn't work out but i
stayed because i actually started to
like it
um actually joined the military to
impress a boy
yeah i know right it was weird so when i
came out about it on twitter i had like
this huge imposter syndrome no one
expected that of me but
like you're not like so you can join
this thing but you're not like you don't
have to join the military no
well okay so the one in that i took in
high school which by the way uh mine was
actually the strictest in the entire
country this isn't just me saying it
like it
you can look it up but like when you can
join military if you want and you get
credited more like when you join
rotc in university or go to military
academies
um so it's like an extracurricular yeah
but if yeah basically
um but you get credited really well
especially at the one that i went to
how many hours a week would you do for
it well
the average high school student has
eight classes rotc
is part of that schedule plus another
one so i had nine classes
so what'd you have to do in military
school oh god um so a lot of people have
misconceptions that like you have to
learn how to fight and use a gun or
whatever but that's not for high
schoolers
was it like super strict you have to
wake up at a certain time so it's a very
disciplining thing it's not for everyone
a lot of people um
get out in their first year i stayed for
all four um but basically
like so you have like once or twice a
week you have to wear your uniform and
yet it has to be completely perfect they
look at every crease and fold like you
had to iron it well
like every time i i put my hair up in a
bun they had to check for a little fly
away so that [ __ ] had to be like gorilla
glued down you know
which i didn't have gorillas which i
didn't know you saying this makes
so much sense because like we obviously
we hang out like
outside of this and i think this has
caused me to have the biggest wrestling
[ __ ] face ever and i'm i'm like
there there will be certain moments
where you go into what i call akimon
mode
yeah right where you know everyone else
is a [ __ ] monkey and then you're just
like there
and you're just there to sort [ __ ] out
yeah it's when something goes wrong it's
just like okay
mum mode activities yeah yeah yeah like
what are you doing what are you doing
i'm gonna sort this out i'm gonna sort
that out yeah yeah yeah
hearing this makes so much sense now she
walks into a room and it's like there's
not enough discipline in this room
it's time to slap it so like so the
program i was into it's an extremely
disciplining course and you get credited
a lot
back if you go into university what's
like a typical day uh so
in the school you have to like go
through inspection so you all march
outside and then you stand at attention
and you have to just like
you have to learn the art of not showing
any expression
and then you have to sound off uh like
so someone comes in front of the drill
inspector
and then instructor and then he asks you
a question
and then you have to yell it in his or
her face and say sir ma'am and
answer the question that he had if you
stutter then you get chewed out a lot
like so you it's a very disciplining
thing they're like like
so for example um in front of me like
you would [ __ ] your pants every time
like when it was inspection first thing
in the morning so if i had a girl in
front of me
i'd be so nervous i'd say like good
morning sir and then she'd chew me out
a lot chewing out as in like screaming
oh yeah yeah
chewing out is the term that we use when
you're getting yelled at a lot yeah so
um oh and then along with i don't know
if any other uh
rotc course ever did this in high school
as well but
um i did train also for four days every
year um at usmc united states marine
corps
uh in san diego and that's with real
drill instructors where you have to
go into the barracks you get pushed so
bizarre yeah i know i'm telling you i
had a huge big imposter syndrome and i
can't believe i never came out about
this on the internet
but um yeah because it just completely
goes against your personality
i know it's like i told you there's a
whole different part of my life that has
nothing to do with it because
all i think of when it comes to like
military classes like you know that's
seen in [ __ ] full metal jacket
yeah yeah the dude's just like [ __ ]
yelling at me i've honestly thought to
make a video of me reacting to military
movies and like rtc movies just to see
if they're accurate enough
but like yeah um ex-military
professional oh yeah
like so i'll just tell you this like
that being at usmc
uh you're never gonna get like more
verbally abused than like having four
marine instructors yeah yeah um so
what when did you decide you weren't
gonna join the military oh oh
that was because if you completed all
four years i guess how many how many
like what percentage of the class
that completed four years went on to
join the military
wait oh like oh everyone that enlisted
like how many guys like how many likes
how many ended up going to the military
she went to the military i'd say like at
least like
maybe half yeah like yeah it was 50 50.
because the thing is is like when you're
in this program it's like four years you
figure out you don't like it
well no because like you know people
join this program not just to join the
military it's because it looks very good
on your resume so like you can literally
do a lot of things just by saying that
you even did this in the first place
because
it's literally like not for everyone
it's like doing like you know duke of
edinburgh right yeah
it just looks good on your resume yeah
that's what they said yeah that's what
they said i'd say like
when you first when i first joined um
every friend that i made i'd say i like
i only had one friend left by the end of
it like and
you know um did you enjoy it you know
what you feel actually a sense of
accomplishment
when you do it especially you sound like
you're enjoying it no
no no like
if when you're in it like every day of
your life you're like [ __ ] your
pants like not wanting to get yelled at
and it's like i really hope i don't [ __ ]
up like shining shoes and all that like
and just the physical and mental like
why people would want to do this
it's because it makes you because you
toughen up and i feel like people are a
lot stronger there's other ways to
toughen up i feel all right
yeah it's a learning experience and i
feel like in any other situation people
would call what i went through
abuse but like you go in like and with
the possibility of going to the military
and you have to be strong
so in order to do that you're pushed to
your limits i've met some people who
joined because they felt like they
needed
someone to like guide them like tell
them what to do
yeah and get their [ __ ] together pretty
much and it's not for someone who
doesn't like being told what to do i can
tell you that uh
yeah and the actual marine corps base i
remember
like you'd wake uh you'd be yelled at
for like pretty much the entire day
then you'd go to bed at like midnight
and you get to sleep for four hours and
that's the only time of peace that you
have to yourself and that four in the
morning
uh the drill instructors like come
banging on the door and then they like
rip your sheets
off and then they tell you to get up and
you have to stand at attention but
you're like all dizzy and stuff
and then by the time i uh i ranked up uh
to chief petty officer which
i guess it's just high ranking i got to
be one of the people to chew out
other like cadets that would have been
fun you know what i'm gonna
feel so satisfying so yeah i went
through like three and a half years by
this point being yelled at and then now
you get to be the person
to yell at other people a bunch of
psychopaths
so basically like we'd have like our uh
our um
i guess our like a platoon later uh we'd
be lined up in front of the door of like
our assigned cadets and then she'd like
whisper and count to three like and then
on three you all have to like smash the
door and
get open and then just basically like
[ __ ] kool-aid man essentially yeah
that's essentially what i did and i made
a few people cry
uh at that so i'd like to get so loud
because yeah it's like a badge of honor
but it's because like it's so unexpected
uh when you first meet him achievement
unlock course trauma yeah
we've got three cries in here yeah no i
don't want to see your
medals or achievement how many people
you made crying how many kids you made
christ yeah
so no that i don't know it was a
learning experience and again it's not
for everyone but once you're done like
you're at least proud that you did it
that's that you know what that
equivalent is that's the equivalent of
like you know being like
the the youngest in high school and you
having to like wait for the seniors to
go on the boss
yeah and then when you become the senior
you're like out of the way i waited five
years for this [ __ ]
that's exactly what that is all i'm
thinking is you must have really [ __ ]
liked this boy what
like oh i mean like you know i was a
freshman i was like 14 or 15
so yeah but still even even if there was
like the girl of my dreams and she's
like
finna go to the army you want to come
i'll be like i'm good
i'm good i wasn't really like told
properly like
how strict rotc was and i didn't realize
that we were the strictest in the entire
country
but then you were yeah but you would
figure that out like first couple of
times yeah but then i said
the person who's like i'm gonna do it
and ask questions afterwards no i am and
when i
when i was experiencing it like i stayed
because i was like i don't know i
actually really like this
what did you like about it i don't know
because like it's really pushing you to
your limits to rank up
you have to do well in academics and you
have to do well in physicals and you
have to completely like pass it with
flying colors if you want to get
to the rank that i did which took four
years so so
you say you got into this because you
liked a boy yes
was that was there like a point or a
moment when you like in your first
joy isn't working in your first year
when you just like when you just had
this realization of
oh [ __ ] this is what i've gotten myself
into [ __ ] me
oh yeah no that was like like in the
first day
i feel like and yeah you were like four
years easy i feel like without people
like you we wouldn't have raves because
you know you're the kind of person who
would turn up something like well i
guess i gotta do it now yeah
no one likes the rave when they turn up
and i just leave but it's funny when i
was 18.
i'm committed i'm here now what's funny
when i was 18 i actually held a rave
that was during a very different hockey
time
where my house what you held up raving
your house
would would execute me yeah if they
found that american pipeline
that was uh that was a very crazy party
but yeah i think nowadays um i have my
fault like
other like fellow cadets i went with
like they send me dms and they still
call me by my last name
they've no they never we never call each
other by our first names
um and they're just like holy [ __ ] like
you're on youtube and meanwhile like uh
something too with like mine
oh really build provider yeah have any
of your friends that's my taxes
have you guys ever like seen like it
like messages from like people that
you didn't even talk to like that
recognize what you do now yeah
all the time i actually i actually got
one message of
this uh this person who i hadn't talked
to since school
and uh she she's a teacher now so
um last time i met her was like years
and years and years ago and she messages
me out
of the blue to be like yo um
i haven't talked to you in years but uh
can you do me a small
favor she that's never a good sign
and uh she asked me to record a message
for her for her students because
apparently her students were like big
fans of me
um and and i was just like
you know what [ __ ] it i'll do it you
know you can be
you can be the cool teacher for your
kids i'm gonna let you wanna
let you have this right and so i record
the message and apparently after that
she was yeah she was the cool [ __ ]
teacher
so yeah it's it's so bizarre because
like ever since like you know during uni
when i was doing it like i
never told my uni friends or high school
friends that i was a youtuber
so like when i got all these messages on
facebook from like high school friends
that i haven't seen in like
[ __ ] 10 years almost then being like
yo i saw you on youtube the other day
i've been watching you for a while i'm
like what'd you say to that how did i
back to this i was like thanks but also
hey it's been 10 years like what are you
doing
you know it's like yeah like how do you
react to that would you would you guys
go to your high school union union i
don't know
my high school was tiny so like i felt
like i was pretty good friends with most
of them right yeah yeah my house
i think i had like like 30 40 people in
my year
yeah it was really really small i had
like 800.
you had more people in your class than
we did our entire school year
yeah that was yeah we were my school was
attached to another school which is an
english speaking school
and i think one of their years was
nearly the same
size as our whole school which is just
yeah our entire school i think had like
600 kids
yeah something about that yeah something
around that and we were considered one
of the biggest schools too
oh wow yeah really australia really be
all over the place
with that [ __ ] i don't know like because
do reunions happen every
10 years is it i think it is yeah it's
going to be 10 years who because who
arranges these
you know so i recently looked at like to
see if my school was doing one
and usually where are you looking your
school your school's website and there
is a specific section for alumni
there's a website yeah yeah also a lot
of websites oh really
my school has like a section like that
says alumni yeah i've always wondered
who
like is it like someone from the year or
was like one of the teachers or school
my high school union which i couldn't go
to because i i was bidding on ax
i was just in l.a i was busy in l.a at
ax but
uh it was sorted out by one of the
people
in my class so it wasn't even the school
that sorted my one because it would be
because for me it'd be next year 2022
would be 10 years i imagine
that's when the high school unions were
a thing it served a pretty good purpose
which was you could actually see these
people who hadn't seen it yeah
yeah no it's like well i've got everyone
on facebook and
i see that instagram photo like even if
you have some it's true but i feel like
i i feel like the the purpose of it has
really like
diminished yeah it's still good i think
i would still go because i'd like to see
what i want to talk to everyone but
i'd like to i actually really i've
really wanted to go
but i wasn't i'd like to go if there was
like you know the teachers there as well
that you were like
yeah you know like catch up with
teachers that you were really friendly
with surely it's got to be like
you know how depending on how you want
to go depending on is your life better
than when you're in like
school right because some people it's up
or down it should be up
right right some people you know maybe
went down a little bit you know maybe
their golden era was school
right then it's like yeah do i want to
go
that's true like yours was last year
right or this year i guess
what the high school year yeah 10 years
because when what year did you graduate
2011 yeah so it'd be this year yeah it'd
be this year and that's why i was
checking because i was like oh it's
reaching 10 years and i they're like for
us
we have our school's website and there's
literally a section for alumni and it
says like homecoming and
you get to log in and say like are you
going and i saw a list of everyone who's
going
and it's so organized like it's because
our school's actually been around for a
while so they've had the
time i guess yeah valley has a twitter i
think oh really
i don't know if my school is a twitter
oh god yeah and like
i'd be weird yeah i followed my school
on twitter
i think i just wanted to check who was
going but in order to do that i had to
sign up to the website but i think it
put me on the list so then i got these
messages from like old high school
people like being
you're going and i'm like no i'm just
stalking yeah
because i've heard like there are some
high schools where like say like they
don't have a website
where it's literally just someone from
that year being like so i've like booked
the pub
like down the road like what happened
yeah exactly yeah
it was literally just a facebook group
like everyone got invited to and
apparently some people showed up and i
kind of wish i did i
i mean i remember when i was in high
school obviously you see them on tv all
the time high school reunions i don't
[ __ ] see anyone
i hate i'm like that one edgy anime
character who's like right
they don't know they all bullied me back
i really don't know that i'm 1200
raiding in chess
but it's not [ __ ] meme where the guy
standing in the corner being like they
don't
yeah they don't know i'm a pro player
in the first three years i was like i
nah [ __ ] high school really
i'm too cool for that but then more it
goes down i'm like you know what i think
i'd actually like to see
how everyone's going yeah i'm genuinely
curious especially
during quarantine i had this like
weekend when i'm just like
man i wonder what everyone's up to
because i feel like you get that day
one like one day you hire a pi what do
you do no just like just you know you
see what people are up to on facebook
because you haven't talked to them in
years
yeah they had all these dreams and
aspirations you you want do you see some
people who are
able to uh like you know some people who
have just been stuck
in their hometown i feel like most
people wanted that where i
grew up they the whole i think it was
almost expected that you
never really leave the town yeah i feel
like that's like a small town mindset
because i feel like a lot of people uh i
talked to sydney's family a lot and the
people
living in her town and everyone kind of
just stays
in that one town and you're kind of like
you're kind of like part of a clan
and if you leave the clan you're like
just you're banished you're discovering
the clown you're all right
you're like the one who thought you were
too good yeah lifestyle because like
nearly like i think most people in my
family like really all generations
live near the same area like within an
hour drive yeah and that's really weird
to think about
now that everyone lives within like an
hour drive like generations of families
so i'm like wait did no one have the
idea to just like leave
i feel like as a kid as a kid you it's
like really it's a really like exotic
idea to live somewhere else and be
someone new right but then i feel like
you underestimate
just how much you like comfort yeah yeah
yeah
like it it it really takes a lot for
someone to be like i'm going to live
in a new country yeah and even for those
of us who live in different countries
um i know you know there are a lot of
things about home that i'm sure you miss
and even even if you know you really
like the place that you live in there's
a lot of things you miss as well like
it's it's
massive props to you know like i think
all three of our parents right at least
that you know had the balls to be like
i'm just gonna go to this country i know
[ __ ] nothing about yeah so my my
parents took it pretty
like easily for me because it's like
thailand to the uk
philippines to america yeah and mike has
japan to australia right like it's like
like i've always wanted like five
generations
yeah my dna test is like a hundred
percent british like there's no one in
my family
right from any other country in any any
like way
well because like you also like you not
only well your parents not only moved
from the philippines
to america but they also moved to
probably the most like
non like friendly place for like
non-white people right
yeah so i was technically born in
bakersfield california because the labor
clock was ticking but then as soon as i
was born they went to
um uh virginia and then i lived half my
life in a
place that honestly sounds like the
beginning of like an rpg game it's
called mechanicsville
it sounds like something in nino cooney
honestly yeah there's like a jrpg name
yeah and then i i i so starting village
yeah mechanicsville
what was weird is like i ha i didn't
even realize i had like this weird i
guess
almost country twain to my accent until
i came to the west coast
to las vegas and then people were
teasing of like the way i say y'all or
the fact i even say y'all
a lot um so i had to kind of like i
didn't realize that virginia they say
y'all
yeah because it doesn't because you look
at it on a map and it's like oh that's
nowhere near texas
so of course this is not the only place
no but like just someone who knows
nothing about america right like when
you hear y'all you immediately think oh
yeah texas
yeah i think southerner like yeah right
but like virginia is not even in the
south it's like kind of
halfway up almost also like kind of like
the founding ground
so yeah but no yeah but
[Music]
history is so [ __ ] confusing i went
through a weird period where i was
obsessed with your guys's history and
culture
there's so much of it and there's like
so many bands that like i love that none
of my friends in the us can relate to
like i think when we were at karaoke
garn was so surprised i was playing
kaiser chief i predicted
yeah that doesn't seem like or take that
shine
like take that my just to give you like
my mom and her friends love take
that's the kind of demo that they have
yeah the first time she was playing take
that and i saw the music video was like
wow the backstreet boys are really old
basically especially at the uk
backstreet boys for middle-aged women
who are married yeah that's
kind of like their target yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah but like that's the thing right
it's like it's not until you kind of
like
look deep into like the whole like us i
guess like geography
that you realize that oh just because
it's not in a particular area
it doesn't necessarily mean they don't
talk the same way right like i thought i
don't know i don't know what i thought
people in virginia sounded like i
thought maybe they sent it closer to
like people
from new york yeah i don't know i mean
like new york's kind of like its own
thing
i feel like the way like the some
americans are probably hearing this
right now and being like and cringing
because i feel like the way we talk
about american geography
is how we feel when we hear americans
talk about europe or something yeah yeah
yeah
i think like someone from the uk i i
think that
british accents and like where they're
laid out is 20 times more confusing
the us is so easy to keep track of where
someone's from based on the accident in
the uk
it's like oh uh this guy sounds
completely different to person like a
person sounds different from b person
they could either be like two hours
apart or literally five minutes in a
different time
yeah because what's confusing about uk
accents is that you can travel a small
amount of distance
and have a widely varied access well i
mean just
in london there's like 20 different
access right and that's just a city
yeah yeah so like you know whereas in
australia i think australia's the only
con
english-speaking country that doesn't
have regional dialects or
accents they just have like degrees of
like strength
yeah but but that's not based on where
you are that's based on
how far off the coast you are like the
further the further inland you are the
less you are able to understand
it's just an aussie scale basically and
you you scale up
you scale up the further inland you go
it's like oh yeah you're definitely from
the inland if i can't understand what
the [ __ ] you're saying
because like you know like kevin for
example right he's from perth which is
all the way on the west coast
and i'm from the east coast but if you
ask someone who doesn't know
australian accent yeah you do something
we would say exactly doesn't sound
exactly the same
yeah that doesn't work in america at all
like in america you can clearly tell if
someone's from new york versus
california right
pretty well yeah like even like
louisiana or like
like i don't know like just from texas
to california they just say like a lot
yeah i don't know and i wonder did your
obsession with the uk
start with the crown is that why
yeah after you watch the crown you're
like are they british i'm gonna learn
welsh
what yeah can you say that yeah never
mind
they're from massachusetts i don't know
who the hell it was i know i know i just
listened to a band
and then it just got me into british
music and then from there i just got
into british culture
i just happened to also be watching
harry potter at the time yeah but then
somewhere in there but then you watched
the crown and you told connor i was like
i love that you were like trying to like
speak welsh and i was like whoa yeah
no one does this because it was so
pretty like i was just like man
thank you it is i don't know everyone
said no so many people like wow it
sounds disgusting and i'm like
really listen no i think i think well
sounds [ __ ] dope yeah i like
i i like welsh i don't know best flag
disgusting best flag
it's a just a [ __ ] epic it's just a
dragon [ __ ] epic i love that
just a dragon stressed around i'm
actually imagining saying it's
one last point about the flag remember
joey said it's so hard to draw no it's
not you just draw a
basic shape you know it's that flag easy
he's so patriotic he you have a picture
of your flag above your bed
i did i did yeah in london he has a
picture
of him like is that a picture of a
painting is it canvas yeah it was a
canvas
of the welsh flag just to remind
yourself in the morning being like yep
still welsh
because what happened was that when i
was filming videos on that live stream
the thing
my wall was always in the back right
well why not let people know i didn't
know it at the time stop asking me
i didn't know that was your flag at the
time i thought like you know when we
were like on discussions like a harry
potter house
like i always saw it in the back like
behind connor i always thought it was
like some kindergarten project that you
wrote
because it looked like a painting it's a
macaroni aftergarden project because it
looked like painted
like on the little canvas i was like so
cute likes nowadays are [ __ ] boring
right
even back then like what do you mean
nowadays they haven't changed
no because the uk flag is a new flag
before before that we just like all like
these weird coat of arms that were like
[ __ ] badass and had [ __ ] all over
the uh when um you know all the
countries united
yeah it's uh the uh what's going on what
are you talking about
yeah are family crests just the uk thing
or is it
so like uh i think someone pointed out
one time because i said i wore a kilt
yeah to um a wedding it's only for if
you're in a clan in a scottish clan
actually my second name is a scottish
clan name
and then then you would get like a coat
of arms or a symbol oh that's not a
family
uh association that's probably that's
cool
[Music]
you know yeah yeah yeah yeah you used to
be you know it'd be pretty cool to be
like yeah i'm a scottish clan it's bad
actually my second name scottish and a
lot of my
older older family is from scotland so
there's something that's scottish i
don't know what it is about the word
clan those are so much cooler than like
the word family
yeah you know it's like join my family
join my clan family is everyone has a
family yeah
it sounds like it goes to war yeah but
you fight yeah
you fight with you die for each other
you know you don't mother you've got a
blood oath
[Music]
you because like especially in asian
culture
um like one thing that confused sydney
so much is just
we refer to like everyone as like
brother and sister basically right right
right like like so whenever i'd
introduce like some places in america do
that too
no but like southeast asia like if some
stranger i've never met says they're on
my uncle i will 100
believe them like you know what i mean
maybe that's another reason i also have
never like thought of dating like
another like southeast asian because i'm
like
it feels like i'm dating my brother or
whatever honestly i'm exactly the same
yeah
i just yeah i can't get to white guy
i'm just like oh yeah and like joey like
you're just you're just happy so it's
okay
yeah but i'm not southeast asian i'm
just asian when i first
saw you on web uh when i first saw your
videos i thought you were like
like hispanic or middle eastern yeah
everybody everybody says
yeah everyone everyone links me like a
bollywood like star
and it's like this you yeah like that's
the thing
it's like it's three things do they have
the scruffy heads do they have the beard
and is there
browns like uh the skin slightly brown
yeah yeah that's joey
in japan like especially when i wear a
mask and he's wearing a mess people
think that i'm the one that speaks
fluently when really it's joey
yeah i know i hate it i hate it
i mean it's it's useful when you're
taking your friends around because i
like i can tell sometimes when joey just
cannot be bothered to play translator
i love i love doing that sometimes like
i remember i took my uni friends like
my three like australian uni friends to
uh kyoto for the first time
and they'd never been to japan and of
course because i'm the only one who can
speak japanese there or have been to
kyoto of course i had to play the
translator
tour guide but i was like one day i just
woke up i was like [ __ ] i'm so tired of
this
you know what i'm just gonna pretend i
can't speak a word in japanese they'll
never know
and we went to this like really nice
restaurant and i remember the clock was
ticking and we had to order right
now because the place was closing and i
was like joey
we want this this this is this and i was
like uh
eagle menu are you mascara
and no oh that was so pissed off but i
was like you know you know how [ __ ]
yeah yeah i don't get paid for this [ __ ]
no because that's that's why i feel
whenever i have like a friend round in
thailand where it's like it's
you do it for like a week or something
and then it just gets tiring
and it really does yeah
[Laughter]
you have to you just feel like you're
you know hang around with a bunch of
babies and you just got to do everything
right because i feel like guilty will
never ask you to do something because i
know exactly how that feels
like does baby does baby want to meet
you
so yeah one thing i've always wondered
is that you know
one of the difference is that you guys
definitely had a point where you kind of
blew up with
your youtube and everything which was
like kind of unprecedented in our
community
what was that like because i've always
had this gradual growth where i've never
had a point when you know i suddenly
just woke up one day and woke up and
a month later i gained 100k subs or
something like that right i think
because you guys at one point got like
250 000 subs in one month
and i think that's the most it i think
uh hers was bigger i think yeah the max
i ever got was like 150 200k in a month
yeah then you all started collabing yeah
and then i think your biggest one was
almost like 400k a month right
yeah you had like 100k in a week yeah i
uh
ridiculous i remember that too like as i
think i said it earlier
in the podcast that like when i called
you i wanted to throw up
because like i don't know it's like i i
knew i wanted to do youtube but then
once like you see that number going up i
suddenly felt like someone pushed me in
the middle of the stage and said dance
like and then all of a sudden there was
just like this huge amount of pressure
over a video that i didn't even really
take that seriously
and then well because i remember like
you vocalized
because i remember you made like a video
which is like you know those
good old like obligatory like thank you
for 100 thousand subscribers
and then literally a week later i made
it you made two thank you for 200 000
subscribers
i did do it 200k and then like i think a
week later i was like
should i do the 300k i'll just say it in
passing uh in the video so yeah no that
was
really crazy um and i can i still
can't believe that that happened like
over six years ago but
i mean maybe i wasn't really part of the
anime community it's tough to really
feel what that must have felt like
especially for you like where you've
been in it
like really heavily invested i was an
amv which is like a tier of its own so i
wasn't really
i watched uh like a lot of like your
older stuff um
on that old account but um
maybe i don't know maybe i commented on
one of those old videos but
um other than that like i was just more
focused of like what i was supposed to
do
and like that by that point joey and i
had already
made a decision that we weren't going to
work out so we i was just very much on
my own thing and
he was doing his own thing um but yeah
yeah because you've kind of like
transitioned you know i've like talked
to you like more recently
you've definitely tried to transition
away from just doing anime content
like was there anything that pushed you
to do that or was it just like your
interest kind of diverged a bit
uh no i think it's just because like
everything i go
everything i do now is stuff that i'm
just honestly genuinely interested in
and like i said before
like anime just puts japanese culture in
front of you and that's why i called
myself an otaku channel just because
like i'm not here to really give
an analysis on an anime there's so many
other youtubers that i think can do the
job better than me
i mean even though you technically
started in that field though yeah i know
yeah it was everything you didn't know
about was technically an announcement
yeah yeah um but like i mean i didn't go
doing that series to think like like oh
i'm this is going to surpass everyone i
just did it because
it was fun to do at the time but yeah i
don't know um
totally forgot what you had just asked
it's kind of funny that basically every
anime youtuber we know now is
trying to do their best to move away
from anime content okay yeah now i
remember uh yeah so
i don't know i think it's just also it
comes with being a personality
i have that privilege that i can you
know
explore and i know that everyone's gonna
be okay with it as long as i'm in it and
so i just do stuff i genuinely like to
do
um unlike when it was anime i felt like
there was a lot of pressure
that i have to talk about a specific
anime and then like have to talk about
like what's hot right now
what has what is something i can say
that no one else has said when you're
just personality and the world's your
oyster things are a lot more easier for
you
yeah i think anyone who gets like boxed
into any type of content
eventually feels like oh i want to do
something else but my audience yeah yeah
it's literally me i think
i think every single youtuber like goes
through that
one but every single youtuber was
definitely thought about doing other
content yeah and it's either
you know makes a second channel to do
that content or changes
yeah i guess like i almost was on that
path of like
kind of big almost becoming a top 10 top
10 channel
with everything you didn't know about
series and i was like yeah that's a huge
thing back then yeah it was a huge thing
but i was like i don't want to keep
doing this so
i like slowly like i just thought it was
just natural to just
show my face and the face that i decided
to put myself in was the vocaloid one
which i think also
helped perpetuate um my subscriber count
at that point because now you could
see who i was who was the person that
was talking about this [ __ ] yeah so then
through that people wanted to know me so
then i started
i still did vocaloid but in between i
had fillers of who i was and then
eventually
i gradually got rid of the vocaloid
stuff and just wanted to do my own stuff
and now that i'm in japan
i was like what anime fan doesn't want
to go to japan and what anime fan
doesn't want to go
to like you know uh different types of
cafes so i was like i'm gonna just do
just that because i know that my
audience wants to do this stuff and i
feel like i'm kind of like they're
i don't what is it not gateway in i've
i'm like
introduction yeah introduction they're
living vicariously
through through me i guess through this
content and yeah i don't know that's
just the way i
know i get that because like especially
one thing that makes me uncomfortable
um with my own content is when people
kind of
see us as like say ambassadors of anime
where like i'm just a guy who just has
an opinion
what did geeks lost call us again the
heroes of anime
it makes me uncomfortable when people
are like taking my opinion really really
seriously when i say like your word is
gospel
yeah like i like x or like one people
are just like yo
giggup said it he ruined this community
or something and it's just like dude
it's just
i i i don't i know as much as i'm just
meaning i know as much as anyone else
it really says something when like the
audience takes your opinion more
seriously than you take your own opinion
yeah exactly and i feel that way with
just not my
you know my content but with the trash
taste as well when people some people
take
what we say on trash taste very
seriously you know sometimes we do talk
about serious topics but
when it's just something about anime or
something i'm just like come on dude
but one thing i haven't noticed like i
have to ask though true crime
so so for every girl's intuition
so recently i recently we've caught up
and you started talking about your
newest obsession and
some of your new content which uh is
very a true crime-esque you know you've
released we've recently released a video
on the otaku killer
um i found it funny because we haven't
talked for a while
and uh sydney also very much went into
this phase and she i mean she's
like serial killers for a lot of times
but um but now
but now but now it seems like every girl
is
into true crimes and true crime probably
so you want to see from a female's
perspective
i like true crime and i i i don't really
know why i like true crime no no i just
find really i i find that [ __ ]
fascinating as [ __ ] but there's a
difference between liking the content
and it being the first thing i you know
i i did ask one other girl sorry before
you answer i didn't want to
this made me laugh a lot i asked why do
you like true crime they're like oh it's
like preparation
to defend myself since this happens and
i'm like
yo how often are you going to come
across a serial killer who specifically
duct tapes like 10 victims together
yeah yeah because it was funny because
like um you know being with sydney for
so long she's from wisconsin and one of
one of the things they're apparently
proud of is that there are so many
killers that have come from wisconsin so
isn't it like the number
one state like the most amount of serial
killers
come to vermont we have the most sex
offenders
so she had always prided herself on like
you know i i'm the serial
killer otaku and then suddenly in like
the past year or two
every girl started getting into serial
killers and true crime and i'm
i'm just here thinking where did this
come from where did it start
honestly i feel like just the blow-up
has happened because true crime
youtubers
specifically criminal psychology just
started getting recommended and it's
like
awoken something i think we all really
like because for me i never thought of
this as a girl thing until like you told
me
uh when we met up and then i was like no
that's not a thing and then
you know then the next day like i just
remember like
sharla like texted me she's like yes
you're coming up we're gonna watch the
true crime stuff i said yeah oh my
[ __ ] god
this is the thing so so for me
personally i always thought it just came
from me really liking horror and then i
that just
and me taking psychology i love the
reason i loved
serial killer stories is not what they
did but it's like
the psychology that goes through it
because serial killers have a very are
a lot of them are very intelligent and
the [ __ ] that they have to do to get to
that point is it's almost like the more
i read it the more i don't want to think
it's real it seems like it's just so
stranger than fiction
it's so strange so that's where that's
why i liked true crime and then like
with
the youtube channel criminal psychology
i just like it that someone had
you know the patience to take like the
raw interrogation
and break down why they ask these
questions because you can't help but
applaud some of these like
um interrogators that they do this for a
living and they know exactly what
questions to ask you
not for you to answer but to just see
how you're going to respond yeah like
sometimes they leave you alone just for
you to stew in your own thoughts and
i just and god was laughing at this
because i was like i sometimes feel like
when i watch it i'm the one being
interrogated
like i feel like i have to lie myself
out of this i'm just watching the
[ __ ] thing
but yeah so then i started the true
crime stuff in japan because
in japan i've always just thought you
know there's always a thing everyone
knows that crime is really low in japan
but when [ __ ] happens in japan it's from
like zero to a hundred it's like
in in america it's nothing like it's
weird take this with a grain of salt
normal
like guy kills girlfriend for cheating
on him right it's not that it's like
i'm going to like burn everyone alive
and like post it like on 2chan just
because i feel like it
and it's like nothing builds up between
that so my true crime stuff is like i
want to look back of what the [ __ ]
happened to this it's like an episode of
black mirror sometimes
essentially yeah you know in in the us
they might assume that it could be
something bad that's happened right but
yeah because you know crime doesn't
happen that much the police never like
think to
that this guy might be going after
children yeah yeah yeah yeah you know
also like one and they all i've also
noticed that with at least japanese like
true crime a lot of like uh i guess
people in japan don't talk about it
because they don't like it
yeah it's like no don't forget it let it
be yeah so it's really interesting
seeing like
people i like yourself trying to find
stuff out about it because it's like so
buried because they don't want to talk
about it yeah yeah
pretty much and so i'm freaking out i
completely forgot
but then like i totally get the
obsession in that right and i totally
get like you know watching these
interrogation stuff
super fun yeah but like there's a
difference again between like
you know looking at an interrogator
doing his job and being like wow the
psychology behind this is [ __ ]
fascinating
and you know [ __ ] waking up like
seven in the morning and you just
from the living room you just hear his
arms
her eyes were a gaucho okay and i go in
i'm like what the [ __ ] happening
you're just like sitting at the table
eating cereal like
like it's nothing that's just our
mornings i was like morning of joey
other to be like
did you wake up to true crime podcast
yeah and you're you're girl listening to
two kind podcasts because i do
yeah yeah yeah yeah charlotte is telling
me i'm just it's like the sunlight's
coming through the birds are chirping
it's a lovely day and
you just hear like and and so he
brutally murdered these girls in the
most gruesome way possible here's how
they did it number 10.
number 10. remember we even went up in
the to the north and we uh we were
meeting sharla
and then like you guys wanted to go to
bed but she's like uh like
hey guys i'm gonna go upstairs does
anyone want to watch the true kind thing
with me i'm like i'll do it and then
she's like all right let's go
literally yeah yeah yeah me and my
friend was just like all right
see you later have a nice day i don't
know it's just like because it's just
people talking and well no i'm not
awesome
yeah but then but then at the same time
right it's it's it's the it's the
double-edged like thing of like you know
what the girls will be like yeah
we love watching true crime but then
when you tell a girl that you know you
watch the two-hour frederick newsome
down the rabbit hole video they'd be
like why would you watch that
yeah like bro they they're amazing what
do you mean
meanwhile i was like i don't want to
watch a two-hour down the rabbit hole
upside down i am going to go with a six
hour interrogation
with some guy commentating over it like
button like shut the [ __ ] up
just like i bet he's thinking about our
other girls this is just the boys
watching super monkey balls
did you watch the netflix documentary
about like the uh i think it's like the
hotel
it's about like the yeah the hotel where
they find the girl
in the uh the water tower oh the water
tank yeah that's
really fascinating i really liked that
one because it was like you thought like
it's about this case and they suddenly
were like
yeah so about these redditors man yeah
it was really cool because it actually
like because it was quite recent
it was like giving you the perspective
of the cops at the time and they were
getting so
frustrated the people online kept trying
to [ __ ] solve the case right wouldn't
stop coming up with crazy ass conspiracy
theories
and it made me think it was like i was
like yeah yeah it must be so
[ __ ] annoying being a policeman now
where everyone is trying to do your job
yeah like release every detail i was
going to watch that documentary and i
brought it off to akio i was like oh
they they made a documentary about the
you know this case and she's like i
already know yeah she already knows
themselves
so i never ended up watching it i gotta
ask like because if you
consume a lot how what like where is the
line with youtubers
talking about like real life cases what
what i mean like because
do you think it's free game they could
say whatever they want conspiracy
theories and all they can talk about it
like
because it's like kind of rough because
it's like you only have x amount of
facts right
so yeah are you allowed to talk about so
i went pretty [ __ ] deep with the
otaku killer one
um with that one theories right like you
just told the case yeah because
yeah when it comes to presenting
theories i would say that like
uh i don't know because for me i want to
go over cases that are already
like closed right right by that point
like and it's been a substantial amount
you don't want to accidentally solve a
case because
okay so i don't know if you guys knew
about like you've probably heard of that
twitter killer in japan
i didn't even want to touch that because
that was still going on and i didn't
want to [ __ ] it up yeah
like with my video you know i feel so
bad for these like like in that
documentary as well like the cops and
also the families like
this whole documentary was going on
about this hotel you should watch it by
the way what is it called do you guys
know
no i don't i don't know what it's called
i'm sure it's a good documentary
my problem with a lot of netflix
documentaries i found not find nowadays
is that
it feels like they drag it out yeah i
remember because
i knew i knew the basic details of this
case because i've
heard it from like second hand just
hearing sydney listen to different cases
so i knew the case
and i was like okay maybe i'll find out
a bit more about the details
and then i watched 60 minutes and the
first episode was just literally
building up the hotel itself and i'm
just like yeah
i already know what happens who cares i
don't care about it yeah yeah
it's a skid row it's a bad hotel they
focus on this couple who's just
this british couple was like staying in
a hotel i'm like i don't give a [ __ ]
about a couple let's get to them
please that's been my big problem it was
really interesting because it was like
the only one that like
looked at like the online critics or
online like people were trying to solve
it in like a critical way
because there was another one that was
called like don't [ __ ] with cats
but i could not [ __ ] stand the girl
gentlemen oh my god
you know how she's presenting it like
just a couple of guys online
no that was all murdered it wasn't even
that it was just like we're just like
internet nerds just trying to like yeah
it was like oh god
i i i understand that like you know the
modern cases a lot of interviews but i
like the way don't [ __ ] with cats builds
it up like it doesn't even
it does it doesn't it they don't even
show you luca mcnaughton's face until
the very end even though they easily
could have because they
want you to like see everyone's
perspective like that was involved in
this
that one was crazy and it would have
been so much better if they had just
replaced that woman with just a standard
narrator or something else like
i no no offense to the woman i just it
was it was infuriating yeah yeah
how she was just talking about cats
being murdered and then she was like
whoa
that was wacky and then we found him
killing other people
or if she could have just like like
stuck with the fact that it was the
acting
yeah you don't need to act on something
that like like is about murder and cat
yeah
like i'm i don't need this like i don't
need to know the personality of the
presenter like i just just give you the
facts
i think one one of the big reasons i
could never get into true crime or like
i i've never been able to fully invest
in it it's just because
it it feels like to me like i know
it's not unintentional but it feels like
to me it's you you kind of view this as
like a fictional story you view it
as like an entertainment kind of an
entertainment based thing yeah and
i remember watching don't [ __ ] with cats
and very
very fascinating story that's not that's
not what i'm saying and they had a
segment on this but
it just feels like it just for me it
feels a little bit
wrong or i just feel a little bit dirty
when i know that i'm watching this for
entertainment when
i'm i know that someone got [ __ ]
murdered and
that this is like some families lives
has perhaps
has been ruined by this and you know all
the attention is
on the merger and i know they did do
like a segment on you know how nobody
remembers the victim and that's just the
[ __ ] ugly truth
and that's why that's the big line for
me when it comes to like true crime
and watching like a good horror movie or
a good like fictional story is that i
can't
i can't like wash away these feel this
feeling that i'm just kind of like
listening to this like i'm i don't know
what the right word is but it's just
like
i'm reviewing this real life event this
real life tragic event
as an entertainment piece because that's
what it is it's an entertainment piece
and that's that's kind of like
why i've not been able to get into it so
would you prefer it then say
hypothetically if they like you know
properly go over like the
the family like i don't know what the
right way to go about it
it's just maybe there is no right way i
don't know i don't know if there is
right it's just
it's just my mental vlog because you
know i find something like for example
monster
fascinating because it's like a really
deep character study on you know what it
means to
are you born evil or is evil something
you learn along the way
right but the reason i'm in the reason i
can invest in it is because i know it's
a fiction there's that's
that there's that barrier that i know
that no it's like that moral barrier
right yeah it's kind of like i guess
telling you know story about wars and
stuff though as well right there's
tons of death in that and you know
that's just because you know
you know more often than not you just
used to tell stories about stuff that
had happened
in real life yeah even though they have
to unfortunately i think at times
stories do have to be boiled down
in a way that will make people listen
yeah so it does almost yeah like you say
like i mean i understand why the story
needs to be
said and why it almost does feel wrong
that it's entertainment but i understand
completely why
it is that way yeah like for human
nature
we've always been telling stories about
horrific things yeah because they're
stories
and and the stories and you know
sometimes i feel you know it
it it feels i don't know if wrong is the
right word but it just feels
weird to have it presented in a way that
is entertaining
i will admit though the modern like gold
rush
of true crime is getting a little bit
weird
yeah like it's starting to feel a little
bit uncomfortable yeah how much stuff is
being milked and how much it's being
like
kitchen nightmares editing-esque yeah
it's like
it used to go from these are the facts
of the case tonight mary didn't know
what was coming
and then it came the point is if you
just present the facts of a case it's
boring it's [ __ ] boring and yeah i
especially feel this whenever
i watch like american news broadcast
versus like british news broadcast
because british news broadcasts are like
the most boring news broadcast ever yeah
and
in america i remember the first one went
to america turned on the news and it
felt like i was watching a movie
yeah like i did ask didn't know
sometimes if i was watching the news in
america i was watching an episode of the
cops right yeah yeah yeah
because it's it's edited in the exact
same way yeah
where it's just like it's a little too
like yeah it's a little too i guess
you know and that i guess kind of boils
down to like that whole
genre of films of like exploitation
films right it's like it's like some
people find it really [ __ ]
fascinating yeah well other like
that's not really cool i also really
like documentaries because i like to
figure out i'm like alright who are they
trying to get me to root for
yeah what are they because it's someone
telling a story right and they've
carefully picked out all these
interviews carefully ask people
questions
to present it in a certain way and it's
fun sometimes i like watching it just to
figure out like
why are they trying to make me think
this way why are they trying to get me
to
get have this opinion the next character
which is really interesting i guess
that's what made like uh tiger king so
good right
yeah yeah yeah there's a video about
like quinton reviews about it yeah
about documentaries it's really good
yeah because i i think i think what made
me realize this is watching don't [ __ ]
with cats where
what was his name again wasn't luca
mendona
yeah yeah luca where
all he wanted was to have the spotlight
and what was to have the attention and
i remember i remember at the end
thinking oh he
he [ __ ] succeeded this is everything
that he wanted i don't know
this is literally like dark knight joker
he got a four-part netflix documentary
series dude
he was like he was the real winner out
of this yeah
he just felt it just felt dirty to me i
was just like damn man
i don't know and yet yeah i guess when
that when his
soul aims to get attention and then he
gets it that is kind of yeah
yeah i mean i just think it all just
comes from the human nature of like
looking at a car crash that you can't
look away from yeah yeah like you we
love to torture ourselves one thing i do
want to know is that because
i wake up to this and i hear a different
story or like
i hear i hear a new episode every time
okay
how how many stories have you listened
to how many
how many like how deep does the true
crime well go that's what i wanted yeah
because i feel like the
the the gentleman have only stepped into
the kiddie pool right like
yeah yeah i'm no i'm sick of it because
i've watched so many now that i can like
feel like the formula being formed yeah
yeah it always starts right they're like
you know timmy was a little different
but we never thought
that he would ever do anything like this
and then it'd be like it cut to the
victim and it's like
she was only good things the victim and
then cuts back to the thing it's like
and then something weird started to
happen at school and it's like all right
okay
he was okay he was weird right but like
they would never say this [ __ ] unless he
was a serial killer you know what i mean
like yeah
they find out is that they only remember
bad things so everyone always says the
same [ __ ] about every serial killer it
drives me insane
is that true after you've watched like
ten dollars
you feel like you're going insane
watching more because you're like these
feel
all the same i feel like that with a lot
of especially like
i i'm again i'm making this sound like
it's [ __ ] film but like
western crime like i it starts to feel
like the same thing
but i mean i don't know um
sorry again um i feel again
i mean with my series and like the one
in japan every case
isn't really the same in my opinion
because
i mean i don't know though at least i
literally have no i wasn't saying that
the case is the same it's how the
the documentary makers present the story
well the thing is like with true crime
podcast or true crime youtube videos
that i can see it's not always like a
documentary it's lit
literally just listing out the events
yeah
because to me it feels like i've i've
seen like i've seen like top 10 lists of
like the weirdest crimes or like the top
top unsolved problems we have top 10
deaths
caught on camera my favorites are the
top 10 breakdowns in courtroom cases
unsolved crimes yeah and like you you
you go through one topic like what
dictates number seven over number eight
like i don't understand they're both
horrible and like i've you know i've
heard of a few and and
you get to a point where you know it's
like it's like asking people what their
top 10 anime is
after after you've seen enough anime you
see you see that you see the same cases
yeah you know what to say you know what
everyone's like i love um
sorry you know what the mainstream anime
are right yeah that's what i feel like
what are your top 10 crime cases
list them off chill style oh my god
number 10.
do you want me to list like like off the
top of your head what what what are some
of the ones that you stick out to your
mind well i literally have like a
bookmark
like list like this [ __ ] big on my
computer favorite true crime documentary
like
it comes to mind like when you think oh
god
legit like don't [ __ ] with catchers is
perfect to me honestly
but honestly that was perfect uh besides
like the chick
the fact that like you know this is a
closed case and yet you feel like you're
it's still open like i don't know the
whole presentation
love those videos where it's like it
presents itself it's like a really big
mystery
and then like you know they're like like
two episodes in and then they present
like what actually happened like the
very plausible very simple explanation
and then
but some people don't believe that and
then it's like 30 more minutes of like
complete utter nonsense
and it's just like theories that don't
make sense [ __ ] it's like you
already have the explanation just accept
that it's [ __ ] boring like real life
is
well because like weirdly enough you
didn't really like tiger king
no i actually which is weird because
like you'd think
that that the the you know the fact that
you know at the end of the day
it's a true crime right it's a true
crime story that's just a little bit
unique that any of those people got to
be filmed
and yeah yeah yeah but like you didn't
like it i thought you'd like that
yeah i don't know why what was it that
like you didn't like about tiger king
that you did that you liked about
everything else i don't know
maybe i've just seen like seen and heard
so much [ __ ] up stories that like it
was just not entertaining to me
i was like oh yeah you've literally
numbed yourself i honestly i think it's
probably that
was just like watching a playground
argument just unfold but with guns and
tigers i think what i didn't like about
tiger king was the fact that i couldn't
believe these were real people
yeah like i thought i thought they were
playing like i did ask thought first two
episodes i thought they were playing a
character
i i watched it all and i thought [ __ ] i
just wasted all my time
for nothing i'm just surprised how
popular it got yeah
i didn't expect i just really appreciate
especially
i'm rolling back to that youtube channel
criminal psychology just because
like it takes a lot of research to un
like to understand why this
interrogation is being played out the
way
it's not just question and answer it's
like they're trying to like create
pressure for you
for you to [ __ ] just confess i guess
because you have a psychology background
it's like more
entertaining i feel like even without a
psychology background and i think that
shit's just fascinating the way that
it's just presented they explain it like
you're five
right i don't know i like my heart
starts racing like the closer they get
to getting
to the getting that confession out yeah
to get in that confession i was like
here it comes
yeah i've noticed that there's like
reaction youtubers to interrogations
there's people who like watch
interrogations and give their thoughts
on their thing and i'm like
this is kind of that's going too far
weird right yeah
like oh my god i don't imagine anyone
like
you know doing all of that stuff i just
like stopped
interrogation that's like reacting to
public hanging
it's like whoa [ __ ] that just
happened it's like shocked face
uh underscore emojis
yeah yeah we all have that png
it is it is bizarre that it has been
like commodified
you know yeah i don't know what the word
is i was like entertainment fight is
that a word
i actually had no idea that you guys had
talked about the true crime thing on
your podcast so when i uploaded the
otaku killer video
like half my comments are like wow the
podcast was right about you i said
what i don't what joey what the [ __ ] did
you say they called you out
that's all right yeah i don't know i
mean i think obviously due to the fact
that there's
more mobile phones and things are being
recorded more for like the
evidence purposes and reports so there's
just more and more stuff getting
released public journalism right
and this is the side of the public that
this is the side of crime that the
public never saw
right you only ever hear about this
through like stories from cops
yeah which obviously was presented with
full of bias and stuff like this so i
think it's it's just like a
renaissance almost of the public being
act given access to crimes
yeah for good and bad because you know
now those people get outraged all the
time and stuff that cops do rightfully
serves yeah
they pull right like and so it's it's
kind of
i wonder if this will be an ongoing
thing where you know crime from now
onwards has to be
put in mind or i'm like huh what's the
youtube comment going to say about the
way that
you know i wonder if there's going to be
crimes what if there's like serial
killers who are like i wonder i wonder
what clickbait they're going to use for
my well yeah because i wonder now like
if i'm in an interview
i'm being interrogated i might think
well this might be on the issue right
on a good show no i wonder it's really
i guess there's the sense of the way
that like yeah
we've been desensitized to it but also
it's it's a system that hasn't been
built to be
exposed to the public yeah i i i don't
think it's i don't think it's just that
but i because i think like another big
thing is that
the reality i mean the barrier between
like
reality and fiction has kind of like
been slightly broken down because we
sometimes we we kind of view social
media as entertainment nowadays so
like council culture is like a big thing
nowadays and i feel like you know with
so many
youtubers making like apology videos and
outing other people like this you know
there is a reason people do that there
is a personal reason people do that but
we got to admit that to the vast
majority of the public
this is just watching this is just
entertainment you know this is just
watching the high school
this is listening to high school drama
and gossip and
like it it's it's what it's slowly
turned into where you know it's
our entertainment has just become other
people's reality
this is this is our modern day reality
tv see
i can see the difference i i've
mentioned this to a couple of people but
like
you know it it still only just seems
like a few years ago like
when the internet and real life they
were just there was a such a thick wall
between two of them like
you could tell that anything that was
said on the internet was not taken
personally and then
like being in reality it was whatever
but now
you know the news gets like half of
their [ __ ] from twitter yeah you know
reality and the internet has fused so
heavily into each other
that everything you post that's the kind
of person you are at least that's what
legit like serial experiments laying
like straight up yeah essentially yeah
like 10 years ago it would be like oh
did you catch the latest love island or
big brother did you hear what x did yeah
and now nowadays it's more like yo did
you see that apology video oh yo that
was uh
did you see that twitter dude yeah that
that was that was yeah that was it yeah
likes on that twitter and it's just like
okay
and we are kind of commodifying other
people's drama in that case essentially
yeah and people's lives are being ruined
over just people just trying to you know
create conspiracies out of just
posts some of those posts like are just
actually a lot of those posts are just
twisted to make
these conspiracies of anonymous people
that honestly don't give a [ __ ]
about you and it ruins careers it ruins
lives it ruins people's mental health
and i feel like i don't know i i kind of
hope at some point that that line of
like anonymity
not caring about other people on the
internet like where is the line going to
get drawn
i don't i don't know because i don't see
it stopping and that's the problem and
one of the biggest things i see now is
like it doesn't matter
what what you know how right you are in
the court of law because what's
more important nowadays is the court of
public opinion essentially and it's it's
a really unhealthy way to think about
things because you know it's
sometimes i do feel you know that like
there is like sometimes online witch
hunts and
sometimes you know it's it's it's it's
so broken down to basically basic mob
mentality nowadays
and it can get really dangerous um so
that's why i tell people that anyone who
wants to like be a youtuber or any
influencer on the internet it takes
thick skin
uh a lot of thick skin you have to
always be prepared for the inevitable
that there will always be a community
out there
who like you you'll be a scapegoat to
someone anything and everything you do
and say
will just be wrong like to these people
and they will wait for you
to [ __ ] up so badly where they can
finally drag you down and
i don't know i i just feel like that's
one of the biggest reasons why there is
this whole side to my personal life that
i want nothing to do with youtube
because then
at least you know i want to be able to
everything's being monitored
essentially yeah i feel like people who
get like i guess canceled really badly
on the internet
it affects their own personal lives to
the point like they cannot live normally
like
there's a i don't know i feel like on
the internet it's
if you make a mistake you deserve to die
kind of mentality and there's no second
chance
the thing about council culture nowadays
is that you know you know we
would you know you know we're trying to
counsel people who say don't deserve
that fame or something like that but
it's gotten to the point where
if someone get if someone is getting
cancelled people who are not even
in their circle yeah or hear and talk
about it like
most of the people some of the people
that you know have this big apology or
cancel
or was getting cancelled i have never
heard of these people yeah until they
got cancelled like i have nothing to do
with that industry
or in their circle but as soon as
they're getting canceled as soon as
their drama
suddenly it's literally everywhere
literally everyone has to have an
opinion on it
and they kind of throw around that name
as if you're the weird one for not
having an opinion on it
yeah it's like i've never heard of this
dude you know what people like
what's your opinion on them getting
cancelled like i just knew about them
five minutes ago
you know what's sad about all of this is
like when someone gets cancelled right
and you
eventually twitter does like kind of the
math work of seeing where it came from
and the person it came from
then let's say that that influencer that
got cancelled finally calls out the
person who started it all
that person all they have to do is just
close their account run off as if it
never happened but then the influencer
has the damage left over
and has to deal with trying to repair
their reputation over something that
probably wasn't even a big deal in the
first place
because the big problem i see is that
you know the big difference between this
and say reality tv shows is that
people signed up to be [ __ ] clowns on
reality yeah exactly
they knew what they were getting paid to
be clowns yeah they're getting paid to
be clowns and they sign themselves up to
be like commodified and
viewed as a piece of entertainment but
like nowadays literally that could be
anyone with a social media account
that could be anyone who has an online
without their permission
at all and you know some you know some
people have done some pretty bad stuff
but like what the problem that nowadays
i the problem nowadays is that i feel
like
even if someone did something bad i
can't help but feel that some people
are just looking for that five their
five minutes of fame even if you know
something bad did
really happen to them and i'm not like
i'm really hoping this doesn't come off
that i'm trying to victim blame or
something like that because that's
really not what i'm trying to say
because it it feels like it it can
sometimes feel like not every case but
in some cases that
people are just doing this for the cloud
they're doing this because they know
they can get some attention out of it
and that's why people people are gonna
like rag on about them for a while but
then they probably in the back of their
heads
they probably know by a week yeah it's
gonna go back to them and that's why
like we
we start and we start ending up like
[ __ ] ranking
apology videos being like yo he [ __ ]
slam dunk this person in the apology
video i do love the
dear list for apologies but like you
gotta you gotta remember
these are people's [ __ ] lives that
that we're judging him these things
it's not about who's actually right it's
about who can present their case the
best yeah
it's about pleasing the court of public
opinion rather than
you know being behind the scenes he was
actually morally right or wrong
honestly like i'm just gonna say i
really hate how there's like a sense of
humanity just taken away from us like
the moment that you become someone
in the public eye like you can't make
mistakes you are not given second
chances and every mistake you've made
that is you and you're a piece of [ __ ]
and there's no redemption there's no
room for redemption
on the internet so that's why you know
i'm just going to say every human being
i'm just going to just say right here
just in case i know it's going to happen
like i'm going to make a mistake and i'm
going to learn from it and it's whether
up to you guys if you want to forgive me
or not but it's through those mistakes
that you can change as a person and i
feel like
it's the most basic thing that everyone
knows and yet we just kind of blow it
off like it's nothing because
you know we're public figures that ruled
up for some reason does not apply to us
or whatever
so i don't know i've i've always just
wanted to kind of get that out yeah i
mean i
you know i don't mean any harm to anyone
and i'm sure i haven't made a mistake
i'd like the opportunity to
fix it right yeah it's very scary
knowing that
that chance might not be given to me
yeah you're like always on the line all
right
it's [ __ ] scary how much a mob can
turn and you know
there are there are people it's it's it
seems like the opposite of the way
things should work because
whenever someone gets outed it's guilty
until proven innocent yeah you know and
and it shouldn't be like that but that's
just the way the mob mentality works
because no one like there's just not
enough people who are like hey why don't
we just wait
and see like because this is yeah
exactly because ninety percent of people
are like
frothing at the mouth ready for the
drama and there's just that 10 people
who are like yeah i mean we could just
wait and hear both sides maybe
yeah it's unfortunate no i don't want to
wait i want something to happen now
it's unfortunate that most people's
reaction to x person to this x thing
is that oh my god let's let's go for it
yeah
instead of being like um did they
they're like i'd say what they said yeah
yeah i think coming from uh like being
more personality based on youtube it
sucks that like
it seems like the only thing that anyone
has to go by is literally just the
videos i've done or any post that i've
made
and it's like i mean again there's every
single person on the internet
has like a whole life like that is
completely different you can't you can't
base a person off of just what their
post says you know i see some of the
weirdest [ __ ] like
oh aki was in a video with that person
she didn't look very happy or like that
person
oh the way did you see the way that they
made this photo
did you see the way that they like
looked at that other person or the way
that like joey just like
did this to his nose who the [ __ ] cares
like your video i was in yeah i was like
i think i was just being me and letting
you guys talk yeah yeah like
all the comments are like man connor
looks really annoyed i'm like
maybe that was just him like maybe conor
has the same problem i do which is we
just have really i'm just really
[ __ ] first i'm angry yeah
yeah no it's just my listening face
that's why i've just been super
transparent that also i'm introverted
and i just want it
it's that whole mentality of you know
the whole [ __ ] i know your life
better than you know your life yeah
like i think i hate that you have to
justify
that every every youtuber you've met
right is like
different steps away from that personnel
personality that they show some people
are exactly the way that they show
themselves
i'd like to think i'm pretty [ __ ]
spot on to how i present myself there
are some people who are like
100 percent could not be more different
from the person
right and it's like two different people
right right and it's it's kind of
you don't know if that is really them so
don't assume that that's how they act
100 at the time
obviously i think one thing that you're
probably is for most people
except like sydney um is that they're
not as energetic
they're not as like high intensity
i think there is a reason for that
though and this is also like applying to
people don't have that much [ __ ]
energy
no and then you know what connor just
said applies to me um
it's like i will be really outspoken on
my video but like i did in the fortune
teller video i literally just showed you
you're very difficult
yeah i'm very different with how i am
with someone else but that's because
like
you know at the end of the day we were
just kids that
i sound like that [ __ ] girl from
don't [ __ ] with cats but we were just
we were just a couple of kids we were
just
we were just you know like people that
had a camera and just happened to
get a following on the internet at the
end of the day we're still in that room
just by ourselves
and when the when the doors are closed
and no one's there we have the
confidence to say exactly what's on our
mind
but you know i feel like everyone has
that problem like you have a lot that
you want to say but the moment like
someone is in front of you you can't
get it out you know what i mean so i
don't know because
i feel like one of the big biggest talks
is talk the most toxic mentality that's
kind of being brought up with
like some some of the newer generation
especially raised on the web is that
they feel like they're privileged to
know everything about a certain case
or so or people's like lives especially
when it comes to a drama
they feel entitled like they deserve to
know
everything that happened even though
it's got nothing to do with them you
know what i really hate that people do
is when people
force two influencers to be friends you
know what i mean like
i so why are you not friends with
so-and-so it's like
because i don't want to be friends with
so-and-so you know like because
i mean i'm i'm a picky person in general
i keep
i like i you can't force me to like
someone like it's going to show on
camera
you you can tell when when two youtubers
i think you said this earlier like
that that's our first time meeting or we
just don't like we're not close
and it shows but then you know and
you're happy that we're finally together
but
i don't know worse than that is i i
haven't met many people who have done
this but
other youtubers who use like that that
pressure from the public
to force someone into being friends yeah
yeah yeah like
you a bunch in a way that like you know
kind of sorry i wasn't understanding
so like you know maybe some like a for
example another youtuber wants to be
friends with you so what the others just
keep tweeting at you publicly
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah or they get
their fans to tweet it yeah yeah yeah
but then if you tweeted them publicly
like the fans reply yeah so they're kind
of actually like twisting your arms
it's a little bit worse than the fan
base of that person tweeting yeah i mean
i i understand why fans do it right
they more often than not they might have
two creators as well so i get it why
they want to see
you know people uh collaborate but it's
quite frustrating when someone in your
position who should know better
does it like i'm you know tweeting at
someone is not i'm not saying youtubers
can't tweet each other
but there is a way that some youtubers
do it and the frequency at which they do
it yeah which is obviously
yeah yeah yeah there's nothing wrong
with like twenty follow me yeah be back
let's talk
yeah there's nothing wrong with like you
know two youtubers tweeting at each
other i tweet at youtubers all the
[ __ ] times yeah
but what's annoying is when every time
it has nothing to do with anything i'm
just like tweeting being like haha yeah
cool and the 17 responses being like
i'm like i just do the same thing when
you talk about collapse you do
collaborate
it legitimately it sounds like a bunch
of seals at sea world it's just [ __ ]
good
i was like no that's not a joke
um yeah like no you sometimes like you
can tell when like a youtuber is really
trying to force their way into your
circle by getting their fans to do it
no nobody will do it but i've i've seen
it happen i've still
seen it i've definitely seen it happen
um but yeah what's another thing on
youtube oh yeah i kind of
i said this like a really long time ago
uh i think with just joey and garn but
one thing
that uh i don't think you were there
but like so you know how like mo a lot
of youtubers say i don't care about the
views and the views don't mean anything
i think it's a load of like [ __ ] at some
point because it's okay to care about
your views because that's like
being at a job and caring how many hours
you're getting how much you're getting
paid
it's okay to care about how many views
you're getting but
like also not being a dick about it i
think the important thing
is to think about the views after the
video's been made yeah yeah people
if you're going into a video with the
views in mind and like what's going to
get the views
yeah you know in a way that's you're
doing it purely for them
yeah obsession way because sometimes
i'll think of a topic and i'm like
this is a popular topic this is probably
gonna have some interest but i'm not
thinking like
this needs to get views or it's done
yeah i'm not like i think that i look
after and if it does well i'm like sick
yeah that's bad i'm like well that sucks
but on to the next thing right
yeah i do sit here because because i i
feel like what i meant when i said that
because i have said i don't care about
the views yeah before
everyone's had that obligatory i'm gonna
defend myself i'm gonna defend myself
where they're like guys i'm just doing
it because i love doing youtube i don't
care about the views
i've i've kept a saying to heart it's
like uh expect nothing and be pleasantly
surprised
because like it's it's gotten to the
point where you know i you
you every youtuber has this point when
they realize that
there's a point in your life when you
realize hey your mental health is really
affected by how well your videos yeah
that's really [ __ ] unhealthy yeah so
like i i had to
get to a point in youtube where i just
stopped looking at the views
like like i had to stop looking at the
views and just focus on the content
that's hard to do
it's it's it's just something i knew i
had to do because
we have this tool i don't know if we've
talked about this before but we have the
tool on youtube
where you upload a new video and youtube
will tell you how well it's performed
out of 10 against your last 10 videos
and
to me it's just a lose-lose game yeah
because you'd never we should show the
trash taste one right now
yeah it is it is the most mind-breaking
mechanic
because it's because what i've realized
is that
it's you you lose most of the time right
because if
a video is below five out of ten
you feel like [ __ ] the entire i guess
i'll die exactly
like we we meme it but like your day can
literally be ruined
oh yeah that's [ __ ] stupid by knowing
that your video performed nine or ten
they also give you like a little [ __ ]
firework animations if you've got number
one yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah but the thing is what i realized is
that if it's like a
four or five yeah you're just like okay
you don't feel good you feel relieved
yeah and that's just so unhealthy
because like that just means the only
time you actually feel good
is when you get the number one or two
which statistically speaking
you can't always get number one or two
and what's worse is like when you do get
that number one
the next thing you expect is well the
next video has to be number one as well
yeah like i just have to keep one-upping
myself and it never happens so like i
always leave
at least like four or five days before
checking the views of my video
right that gives me enough time bro you
must have known november easily then
um i guess before we wrap this up what's
next for aki dearest what's the next
plans what are you going to do what are
your goals uh i'm working on the next on
the case video
all right i've been doing it i can't
give you anything i already would you
say you're more
like a short-term planner like you don't
really think about like like a year or
two from now you're like i'm just
thinking about what's going on the next
month
yeah i feel like it's just good to stay
in the in the present because that just
shapes out how your future going to be
damn that's a tv that's a t-shirt right
now
i was not expecting something i'm pretty
sure i'm pretty sure i've seen people
with chess pieces
i don't know i've been so stressed over
like what could have been or like what
did i do oh man i [ __ ] like did that
yesterday when
at the end of it it doesn't really
matter so i just feel like i just have
to fix it now
i feel like for every one thing i'm like
damn i could have done that i got like a
hundred other things on my holy [ __ ] i
was so lucky with this thing yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's like ah
you win some you lose something yeah
exactly but i guess
uh you want to do the outro jerry yeah
hey if you have no idea who aki is then
as always we'll leave the links to
socials down in the description
and also hey look at all these patrons
who are living in the moment as well
whoa this month oh my god jesus christ
who's who's your favorite patron uh this
one jimmy
you know jimmy you've got a point where
they are yeah
but if you want to be pointed at on
screen blindly then make sure to go over
to our patreon patreon.com also follow
us on twitter
the subreddit and hey if you don't want
to see our faces follow us over on
spotify
but yeah thanks for coming on to the
show yeah you finally come on so you can
stop asking the [ __ ]
when are we gonna when are we gonna
continue the anime show
no that's we don't talk about it we do
not
but yeah guys hopefully you enjoy this
episode of trash taste and uh
i've been with the boys thank you very
much for coming thank you very much
it's been a long time coming yeah and
we'll see you guys in the next episode
bye bye and mike bye
[Music]
foreign